bien mes chers collègues je dois tout
d'abord excuser notre président le roi
Lafond qui est retenu à l'extérieur du
Sénat et qui m'a demandé de d'assurer la
la présidence de cette commission et en
sera d'ailleurs de même demain
matin nous accueillons madame ministre
la culture auparavant je dois dire et
c'est peut-être pour cela que le
président Lafond n'est pas là que il a
été décidé conformément à ce que le
bureau a pris comme décision de limiter
le temps de parole et donc il
m'appartiendra
d'essayer d'utiliser Doren avant le
compteur mais qui est un compteur
pédagogique comme les radars
afin de faire en sorte que personne
n'abuse mais que tout le monde puisse
s'exprimer et surtout finalement et
c'était la raison que Madame la Ministre
puisse parler devant un hémicycle qui ne
se fite pas totalement même si nous
avons toutes et tous ce soir beaucoup de
rendez-vous avec un agenda du Sénat
particulièrement chargé bien donc mes
chers collègues nous avons le plaisir
d'accueer aujourd'hui madame RA Abdou
malac ministre de la Culture pour la
traditionnelle audition budgétaire
d'automne ma chéa vous êes d'ailleurs la
première ministre la première que nous
auditionnons dans le cadre de ces
auditions pour préparer le le PLF nous
nous réjouissons donc de vousetrouver
Madame ministre pour évoquer ce budget
de transformation et d'inspiration c'est
ainsi que vous l'avez présenté devant la
presse et de débattre avec vous de
l'actualité culturelle nous aimons
profiter de ce rendez-vous pour vous
rappeler que vous nous trouverez
toujours à vos côtés dans ces temps
troublé pour faire progresser les sujets
qui nous tiennent à cœur vous pouvez
aussi compter sur nous nous pour vous
alerter sur certaines problématiques par
le biais en particulier de nos nombreux
travaux de contrôle revenonsant aux
multiples défis qu'il vous appartient de
relever dans les mois à venir dans le
domaine de la culture nous nous
félicitons que vous ayez choisi de faire
du soutien aux artistes et à l'emploi un
axe fort de votre politique pour 2024
dans un contexte marqué par les
difficultés de recrutement observé dans
l'ensemble du secteur culturel
depuis la pandémie en matière de
patrimoine nous réjouissons que vous
fassiez de la transition écologique une
priorité absolu en juin dernier nous
avons adopté le rapport de Sabine
Drexler préconisant plusieurs mesures
permettant de concilier les impératifs
de rénovation énergétique et ceux de la
protection du patrimoine comment
avez-vous reçu ce rapport dans quelle
mesure vous êtes-vous emparé de
certaines de ces recommandations
s'agissant du patrimoine religieux nous
nous régissons évidemment des annonces
du président de la République elle se
situe dans le Tro fil des conclusions du
rapport établi par nos collègues pierre
ouias et Anne vintalon mais vous vous
entoutter nous aimerions en savoir plus
sur la manière dont les choses vont
s'organiser que ce soit pour la campagne
de protection qui devrait être lancé ou
pour mieux comprendre les mécanismes de
fonctionnement de la collecte nationale
et la pérennité de cette opération en
matière de musée après une année marquée
par l'adoption du cadre législatif pour
la restitution des biens spoliers et
l'examen de la proposition de loi pour
la restitution des restes humain dont
nous sommes à l'initiative derrière
Catherine Mourin de sa nous constatons
que vous prêtez une attention
particulière aux questions de provenance
comment expliquer cependant la
stagnation cette année encore c des
crédits destinés à l'enrichissement de
nos collections j'enviens maintenant au
aux industries culturelles fortement
marqué par la pandémie le cinéma tout
d'ord que l'on donnait pour mort a
retrouvé des couleurs comme l'avait
d'ailleurs prédit l'année dernière notre
rapporteur Jérémy by avec son à pouroté
et Céline bouletéronier il a conduit une
ambitieuse mission d'information sur le
secteur leurs conclusions ont été adopté
à l'unan é en mai dernier et nos
collègues ont souhaité poursuivre ce
travail en déposant une proposition de
loi le 27 septembre dernier que nous
entendons bien inscrire à l'ordre du
jour du Sénat si le Sénat a repris des
couleurs si le cinéma pardon a repris
des couleurs le Sénat c'est permanent
également
également si le cinéma si le cinéma a
repris des couleurs tenz pas hélas le
cas de la presse travaillé par un modèle
économique fragile et des incertitudes
ude sur sa place dans un monde où les
fausses informations circulent plus vite
que les vraies nouvelles et où l'opinion
surpasse la raison le gouvernement lancé
début octobre les états généraux de
l'information lointain héritier des
états généraux de la presse écrite de
2008 dont nous suivrons le dével les
développements avec attention en
l'absence de Michel log notre collè
notre collègue Pierre-Antoine Lévi vous
interrogera sur les problématiques du
secteur dans quelques instants enfin les
industries culturelles vaste ensemble
sont regroupé à la fois la BNF le jeu
vidéo la musique et l'édition bénéficie
d'un effort important de la part des
pouvoirs publics avec des crédits en
hausse de 7,6 % en
2024 reste cependant à traiter la
question du financement du Centre
national de la musique le fameux CNM en
débit des avancées et des espoirs
suscités par les propos du président de
la République le 21 juin dernier le
montant du budget du centre pour 2024
demeure en suspend on peut déplorer que
cette question identifier depuis plus
années ne soit pas toujours ne soit
toujours pas réglé en l'absence notre
rapporteur c'est notre collègue Martin
lvrier qui vous interrogera sur le sujet
j'en viiens enfin à l'audiovisuel public
madame le ministre dont le budget
représente 4 milliards d'euros je
n'évoquerai pas ici la question de la
gouvernance sujet qui vous le savez nous
tient particulièrement à cœur
je m'entiendrai à celle du mode de
financement et de la redéfinition des
missions et des moyens sur tous ces
sujets les solutions provisoire semble
prolongé nous avons un peu l'impression
de faire du sur place le financement par
une fraction de la TVA est reconduit par
l'article 31 du projet de loi de
finances le gouvernement a-t-il arrêté
un mode de financement pérenne pour la
suite une révision de la loi organique
relative aux loi de finances est-elle
envisagée c'est question vous seront
certainement posé par Cédric Vial nous
sommes par ailleurs dans l'attente des
nouveaux contrats d'objectif et de
moyens pour faire suite aux avenants le
projet de loi de finance compartant en
la matière une nouveauté il prévoit de
possibles remboursements dans
l'hypothèse où les sociétés ne remplirit
pas leurs objectifs une enveloppe
additionnelle de 200 millions d'euros
sur 3 ans est ainsi conditionné à la
mise en œuvre des projets de
modernisation et de transformation des
sociétés ce soit inéit interpelle et
vous aurez sans doute cœur de nous
préciser l'objectif de cette disposition
voilà madame ministre je va vous laisser
maintenant la parole vous vous n'avez
pas de temps limité et cet appareil ne
vous concerne pas chacun de nos
rapporteurs vous interrogera ensuite sur
les sujets relevant de sa compétence à
savoir pour qu'il se prépare Sabine
Drexler pour le patrimoine Karine Daniel
pour la création et la transmission des
savoirs cric Vial pour l'audiovisuel by
pour le cinéma Pierre-Antoine Levi en
remplacement de Michel logier pour la
presse Martin levrier en remplacement de
Michel kouimo et Tok pour le livre et
les industries culturelles chaque
commissaire pourra ensuite bien sûr vous
poser ces questions à l'occasion de
cette audition qui est diffusée en
direct sur le site internet du Sénat
madame la ministre vous avez la
parole merci beaucoup monsieur le
vice-président pour cette introduction
tonique et avec beaucoup de joie dans la
voix ça fait du bien dans la période
actuelle mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs et mes félicitations à ceux et
celles qui ont été élus ou réélus euh
pour cette session nous avons très bien
travaillé ces derniers mois avec euh
cette commission et je me réjouis de
vous retrouver et je sais que dans les
prochains mois nous aurons la même
fluidité d'échange et je connais votre
engagement à chacun et chacune sur les
nombreux sujets qui nous préoccupent
donc voilà une belle année en
perspective de relation de travail
productive et inspirante ensemble
l'année dernière je vous avais présenté
un budget 2023 qui était en forte hausse
plus 7 %. ce budget 2024 reste tout
aussi ambitieux avec un niveau
historiquement haut pour le ministère de
la Culture et une hausse de 6 %. nous
atteignons là en crédit budgétaire
4,4 milliards d'euros environ euh c'est
plus de 141 million d'euros par rapport
à l'an dernier
à ce montant s'ajoute à peu près 4
milliards d'euros consacrés à l'odusel
publ on pourra y revenir 804 millions
d'euros de taxes et de ressources
affectées pour le financement du cinéma
de la musique et du théâtre privé
environ 25 millions d'euros du Loto du
patrimoine l'oublions pas nous l'avons
pérennisé pour 5 années supplémentaires
1,7 milliards d'euros de de mesures
fiscales pour la culture ça fait un
total de 11 milliards environ dans le
périmètre du ministère de la Culture en
2023 c'est à peu près 600 millions de
plus qu'en 2000 en 2024 pardon c'est 600
millions de plus qu'en
2023 si on y ajoute d'autres crédits
budgétaires qui sont dédiés à la culture
par les autres ministères he
principalement l'éducation nationale
mais aussi l'enseignement supérieur et
l'archerche ou même le ministère des
armées pour certains musées on pourrait
ajouter encore un peu plus de 5
milliards d'euros 5,3 milliards pour
atteindre 16 milliards euh pour être
tout à fait juste sur ce que le
gouvernement consacre à la culture mais
il faudrait aussi ajouter les crédits du
plan d'investissement France 2030 ce
sont plusieurs centaines de millions
d'euros qui bénéficient à la culture
notre politique elle se déploie et je
tiens à saluer leur engagement grâce au
travail de plus de 29000 agents en
administration centrale en
administration déconcentré et dans les
services à compéten nationales mais
aussi chez nos opérateurs c'est un
ministère qui forme 37000 étudiants euh
dans près de 100 établissements
d'enseignement supérieur culturel on va
y revenir mais c'est vraiment un vivier
formidable pour se projeter dans
l'avenir
euh aujourd'hui je vais vous présenter
de manière assez synthétique quelques
priorités et bien sûr je je répondrai à
vos questions pour rentrer dans le
détail ce budget effectivement je l'ai
défini comme un budget de transformation
et j'espère d'inspiration parce que
l'objectif il est pas seulement de faire
face à l'inflation il y a une part de
notre budget qui permet d'y faire face
mais d'accompagner des mutations en
profondeur des secteurs de la culture
d'accélérer la transition écologique de
d'accélérer le chantier mieux produire
mieux diffusé notamment pour le
spectacle vivant d'embrasser les
nouvelles technologies de renouveler les
publics d'anticiper la relève des
métiers de mettre l'accent sur la
formation l'évolution des compétences de
redynamiser les territoires il n'est pas
en fait question uniquement de préserver
l'existant mais bien de transformer
notre modèle c'est une année
particulière cette année 2024 année
olympique à plus d'un titre année
exceptionnelle hors norme qui verra
l'aboutissement de plusieurs chantiers
importants la Cité internationale de la
langue française va ouvrir le 30 octobre
au public à villercotteray l'année 2024
sera vraiment l'année du déploiement de
ce projet le Grand Palais va aussi
rouvrir au moment des Jeux Olympiques
après un immense chantier et la
cathédrale Notre-Dame de Paris dont on
attend la réouverture le 8 décembre 2024
euh mais ces grands projets ne doivent
pas éclipser tout le travail
euh de dentelle que nous faisons au
quotidien au cœur de tous les
territoires pour ptisser développer des
liens nouveaux généreux sensibles entre
les artistes et les habitants avec
différents dispositifs l'été avec la
priorité donnée aux zones rurales et aux
quartiers politique de la ville et toute
l'année avec le fond d'innovation
territoriale notre politique d'éducation
artistique tout notre soutien aux
opérateurs aux associations un peu
partout sur le
territoire pour commencer je voulais
vous parler de l'audiovisuel public euh
puisque là ce qui était important et je
m'y étais engagé c'est de donner une
visibilité sur 5 ans et non pas 3 ans ce
qui va déterminer la manière dont on va
travailler maintenant sur les contrats
d'objectifs et de moyens à partir de
mission de service public renforcé euh
discuter aussi plusieurs fois avec vous
suite à différentes missions et et
différents échanges là la nouveauté vous
l'avez dit Monsieur le vice-président
c'est qu'il y a une dotation de base
pour les entreprises et une enveloppe
complémentaire dédiée au projets de
transformation aux priorités aux
coopérations renforcé entre les
entreprises de l'audiovisuel public
notamment Radio France et France
Télévision autour de quelques priorités
claires l'information la proximité pour
accélérer sur les rapprochements France
3 France Bleue la place de la culture et
de la création la jeunesse l'éducation
aux médias euh et la la la stratégie
numérique à déployé plus fortement donc
en fait là on propose non seulement un
budget 2024 qui est en hausse qui tient
compte de l'inflation des effets fiscaux
du au changement du mode de financement
mais aussi de nouvelles mesures qui
sont des des
2024 dans le budget à hauteur de presque
70 millions d'euros et puis c'est des
nouvelles mesures nouvelles enveloppes
elles sont focalisées sur 3 années pour
essayer d'aller au plus vite sur les
coopérations les projets prioritaires 24
26 avec ce système on va dire de
conditionnement à la réalisation
effective des des coopérations et des
priorités on pourra y revenir mais c'est
ce qui nous permet en fait de fixer un
cap ambitieux de transformation pour le
duel public jusqu'à 2028 avec tous les
tous les objectifs qu'on avait déjà
discuter ensemble et avec euh un montant
total de 200 millions d'euros en plus
pour euh ces euh ces priorités mais ce
qui nous fait quand même une trajectoire
sur sur l'ensemble euh de des cinq
années du COM qui sera elle en hausse du
début à la fin puisque on atteindra 4
milliards d' au PLF 2028 évidemment tout
ça à discuter au Parlement à chaque fois
bien sûr euh et euh des euh des
ambitions très précises qui vont pouvoir
trouver leur concrétisation dans les com
qui vous seront soumis évidemment et ça
on a encore des étapes d'échange avec
vous deuxème enjeu sur lequel je voulais
insister avec vous c'est la transition
écologique vous l'avez mentionné euh
j'ai voulu dans ce budget mettre
l'accent en matière de travaux mais
aussi euh de soutien à l'innovation sur
la transition écologique euh dans le le
casre du plan d'investissement France
2030 en plus de budget que du que je
vous présente on a 25 millions d'euros
du programme alternative verte qu'on va
déployé en trois vagues pour soutenir
des innovations on a par exemple aidé
l'année dernière une entreprise qui est
en train de mettre au point un chauffage
décarboné pour les chapitaux ou un
réseau d'opéra qui recycle les décors et
qui salie ça va aussi dans le sens du
plan mieux produire mieux diffusé et on
a obtenu 40 millions sur le fond vert
interminist
pour des travaux qui vont améliorer les
performances énergétiques de bâtiments
qu'il s'agisse de bâtiments de l'État ou
de bâtiments culturel appartenant aux
collectivités en priorisant bien sûr les
structures labélisées soutenu par le
Ministère de la Culture donc ça c'est
une discussion qu'on aura avec chaque
préfet mais c'est extrêmement important
que vous l'ayez en tête pour relayer
dans vos
circonscriptions parce que c'est une
première nous allons
avoir un bout culture du fond vert ça
c'est très important euh vous dire aussi
donc ce ce budget permet hors
audiovisuel d'avoir 241 millions en plus
euh pour euh les crédits du ministère de
la Culture qui se répartissent à la fois
pour renforcer les moyens des structure
de la création accompagner leur mutation
soutenir les artistes la relève des
métiers les écoles de l'enseignement
supérieur le patrimoine les métiers
d'art tous nos grands travaux la lecture
qui reste une priorité extrêmement
importante et l'accès à la culture au
sens large pour les jeunes générations
on a des des petites hausses aussi pour
renforcer le soutien au pluralisme de la
presse et des radio notamment locale et
on a des des budgets supplémentaires
pour les moyens immobiliers et
informatiques du ministère point
important aussi de ce budget c'est
euh les emplois parce que nous avons
obtenu 125 équivalentes en plein nouveau
pour accompagner des nouveaux projets
notamment villeercotr par par exemple 15
emplois mais aussi nos écoles avec 10
emplois par exemple fléchés sur les
écoles d'architecture la consolidation
du Centre national de la musique 10
emplois l'enjeu de la sécurisation de la
chaîne d'acquisition de la recherche de
provenance dont on a beaucoup discuté
ensemble pour nos musées avec trois
emplois et cetera donc on a là une vraie
ambition en matière de moyens humains
renforcés au
ministère en parlant des écoles je
voulais vous vous donner un éclairage
particulier sur ce sujet qui me tient
particulièrement à cœur on a eu
l'occasion d'en parler plusieurs fois on
aura cette année des investissements
structurants pour les écoles de
l'enseignement supérieur une hausse en
tout de de 6 et5i % par rapport à 2023
qui va traduire cet engagement avec des
nouveaux crédits d'investissement pour
poursuivre des travaux de
rénovation que ce soit l'école nationale
Supérieur d'Architecture de Montpellier
ou euh euh le le Conservatoire National
Supérieur de Musique et de Danse de
Paris ou celui de Lyon ou d'autres
écoles à Nice à Marseille à sergis on
aura aussi des moyens supplémentaires
pour les dotations d'investissement
courant un soutien très renforcé aux
écoles nationales d'architecture euh qui
vont avoir des moyens rehaussés de 4
mil8 c'est en tout depuis l'été 2022
depuis mon arrivée ça fera plus de 25 %
d'augmentation pour les écoles
nationales Supérieur d'Architecture je
je continue à maintenir cette priorité
j'ai aussi annoncé une 21e école
nationale supérieure d'architecture
autonome à la Réunion il n'était pas
normal à mes yeux qu'il n'y ait pas une
école pleine et entière d'architecture
en outreem il elle en existait une
rattachée à Montpellier mais on est en
train en lien avec les élus de d'aller
vers le chemin de l'autonomisation de
cette école et de euh sa création en
école nationale pleine et entière ça
c'est un chemin aussi très important
j'ai évoqué les moyens humains
supplémentaires avec les 10 équivalents
temps plein on renforce aussi notre
attention aux écoles supérieures d'art
territorial nous pourrons y revenir
j'avais déjà fait un effort de plus de 2
million d'euros en 2023 ce qui
représentait quand même 14 %
d'augmentation de la dotation de l'État
qui traditionnellement est faible pour
ces écoles qui sont créées par les les
collectivités et qui ont longtemps été
gérées en régim municipal mais on va
renforcer aussi notre soutien en
investissement avec une hausse de 3
millions ce qui représentera plus 27 %
par rapport à
2023 sur le patrimoine je pense que vous
aurez beaucoup de questions mais je
voulais vous redire toute notre
attention également avec un programme
d'investissement qui va là encore
s'intensifier avec des crédits de plus
de 55 millions supplémentaires en 2024
pour financer des restaurations de sites
patrimoniaux majeurs sur tout le
territoire continue la reconversion de
l'ancienne abbaye prison de clairveau le
château de Gaillon les cathédrales avec
notre plan cathédral mais aussi le
Palais de la Porte Dorée le palais de la
Cité le musée guillemets et cetera on
renforce aussi les moyens au
restauration de patrimoine local via
notamment le fond incitatif pour le
patrimoine auquel je tiens beaucoup qui
en majorité presque 80 % des chantiers
soutenus sont dans des communes de moins
de 2000 habitants donc on est vra auprès
des communes les plus petites pour les
soutenir avec ce fond d'investissement
ça a permis par exemple de financer la
restauration du donjon du château de
gubaden à molcrich dans le barrain ou
des parties hautes de l'église de
Belmont sur Rance en aveyon et on a
toute une liste de projets à
venir donc ce fond continue à à
augmenter pour pour avoir finalement son
budget le plus élevé depuis qu'il a été
mis en place en 2018 vous avez mentionné
les les nouveaux efforts pour le
patrimoine religieux des communes de
moins de 10000 habitants et moins de
20000 habitants en outreem c'est les
annonces que le Président de la
République a pu faire au journée
nationale du patrimoine au journée
européenne du patrimoine pardon avec le
lancement d'une collecte que nous menons
avec la Fondation du Patrimoine et une
déduction fiscale spéciale équivalente à
celle qui avait été réalisée pour la
cathédrale Notre-Dame de Paris on pourra
y revenir mais aussi une campagne de
protection
que nous lançons avec l'ensemble de mes
services pour cibler notamment des
édifices cultuels du 19e 20e siècle qui
pourrait être protégé ou classé monument
historique et qui ensuite pourrait
bénéficier du cout de subvention du
Ministère de la Culture pour leur
restauration je pourrais revenir sur le
le détail de ces mesures vous dire un
mot
aussi je peux pas vous dire tout sur
toutes mes priorités mais je ne peux pas
ne pas parler de la lecture qui reste
une de mes obsessions euh et plus les
temps sont difficiles plus la lecture
est le premier chemin d'accès à la
culture à la citoyenneté et aux valeurs
qui nous rassemblent dans cette
république donc nous continuons à
renforcer notre stratégie lecture dans
tous les territoires avec des crédits
supplémentaires en 2024 près de 5
millions d'euros pour amplifier toutes
nos actions pour les tout petits avec le
dispositif première page dans les écoles
le quart d'heure de lecture qu'on va
poursu vivre avec Gabriel Atal l'action
du Centre national du livre avec les
résidences d'auteur les Masterc d'auteur
les résidences en colonie de vacances
dans les épad partout la le concours des
détenus et la lecture en prison bref
lire partout où c'est possible et
continuer à soutenir aussi nos grands
opérateurs de la lecture que sont les
bibliothèques nationales la BPI et et la
BNF
euh surtout que cet été nous avons vécu
avec les violences urbaines des des des
dégradations importantes qui ont ciblé
beaucoup de bibliothèques une
cinquantaine de bibliothèques ont été
touchées donc cet acte 2 du plan
bibliothèque sera vraiment au cœur de
nos
priorités toute l'année prochaine pour
accompagner les collectivités non
seulement dans la reconstruction des
bibliothèques qui ont pu être incendiées
ou vandalisées mais aussi dans
l'extension de leurs horaires
d'ouverture l'animation de ces
bibliothèques c'est toujours cette
ambition d'ouvrir plus mais mieux
également avec plus d'activités plus de
lien avec le passeculture les book clubs
par exemple du passculture qui
fonctionne très bien euh vous le savez
la culture n'en finit pas de de vivre
des secousses crise de l'énergie d
règlements climatiques desésordres
géopolitiques menace sur la liberté de
création des engagements parfois de
certaines collectivités les violences
urbaines que je viens de mentionner mais
aussi les bouleversements induits par
l'intelligence artificielle qui suscite
beaucoup d'inquiétude et je n'oublie pas
bien sûr les risques TER terorist qui
reviennent nous hanter et qui nous
mobilisent aujourd'hui mais moi je reste
persuadé que la culture c'est ce qui
permet de nous rassembler de d'unir nos
citoyens que ce soit dans l'intimité
d'une lecture dans la moiteur d'une
salle de concert ou sous les voûtes
majestueuse d'un monument c'est ce qui
nous offre des émotions uniques des
imaginaires communs ce qui nous aide à
élargir la vie en quelque sorte mais
aussi d'affirmer encore et encore notre
attachement aux valeurs de la République
et ma tradition quand je viens échanger
avec les sénateurs c'est que je ne
termine jamais sans la lecture d'un
poème vous me permettrez monsieur le
vice-président de de terminer avec un
texte du poète marocain Abdel Latif
Laabi qui l'avait écrit en 2015 après
les attentats donc c'est une tonalité un
peu plus grave que les poèmes que
j'avais choisi les autres fois mais vous
comprendrez que le contexte
l'impose j'atteste qu'il n'y a d'être
humain que celui dont le cœur tremble
d'amour pour tous ses frères en humanité
celui qui désire ardemment plus pour eux
que pour lui-même liberté paix dignité
celui qui considère que la vie est
encore plus sacrée que ses croyances et
ses
divinités j'atteste qu'il n'y a d'être
humain que celui qui combat sans relâche
la haine en lui et autour de lui celui
qui dès qu'il ouvre les yeux au matin se
pose la question que vais-je faire
aujourd'hui pour ne pas perdre ma
qualité et ma fierté d'être homme voilà
sans culture pas d'humanité pas de
civilisation possible
merci merci madame la ministre bienentôt
nous allons maintenant prendre parole
des les questions des rapporteurs donc
en commençant par Sabine Drexler pour le
patrimoine merci madame la ministre pour
votre présentation qui était très
complète très intéressante merci aussi
pour ce ce très beau
poème alors en ce qui me concerne
j'aurais souhaité pouvoir vous
interroger sur les suites qui seront
données au rapport sur le patrimoine et
la transition écologique que j'ai remis
en juin dernier alors je me félicite que
mes propositions concernant notamment la
formation surtout celle des
diagnostiqueurs he aux spécificités du
bâti ancien est été reprise toutefois je
tenais à faire part malgré tout de ma
grande déception de constater que rien
pour l'instant n''est été retenu
concernant l'adaptation du DPE de
diagnostic de performance énergétique
aux spécificités du bâti ancien alors
que celle-ci est très attendue par les
associations du
patrimoine dans mon rapport j'ai
également abordé la question du soutien
financier et fiscal qui pourrait être
apporté pour privilégier les rénovations
véritablement respectueuses du bâti
ancien en effet il faudrait pouvoir
réorienter ou alors conditionner les
aides financières et fiscales pour leur
permettre de mieux accompagner ses
rénovations
qui font appel à des savoir-faire et à
des techniques particulières qui sont
parfois plus coûteuses que celles qui
sont préconisées pour le bâti des
trendes
glorieuses aussi pourriez-vous nous dire
si vous êtes favorable comme je l'ai
proposé de réformer le dispositif de
Normandie et malerau mais aussi
d'étendre le label de la Fondation du
Patrimoine aux travaux de rénovation
énergétique à l'intérieur des bâtis dans
le cas où des travaux qui portent sur
l'enveloppe exter eur porterait atteinte
à ses caractéristiques architecturales
ou
patrimoniales que comptez-vous faire par
ailleurs madame la ministre pour mieux
accompagner accompagner davantage les
collectivités territoriales dans
l'identification de leur bâtis ancien ne
pensez-vous pas que les crédits inscrits
à l'action 2 en faveur des études devrai
pouvoir être abondé pour soutenir les
communes qui se lancent dans
l'inventaire de leur bâtis et son
inscription dans les documents
d'urbanisme et ma dernière question
porte sur l'archéologie préventive alors
dans le PLF de l'année dernière vous
aviez accordé une revalorisation qui a
été la bienvenue mais le compte n'y est
toujours pas et la compensation des
frais engagés par les services
d'archéologie des collectivités est de
moins en moins assuré compte tenu de
l'augmentation de leur charges alors
même que la redevance pour la taxe
d'archéologie préventive est largement
excédentaire que comptez-vous faire
cette année pour rééquilibrer ces
financement merci Madame la Ministre
merci merci un parfait respect du temps
imparti excellent démarrage on va
prendre donc toutes les questions des
rapporteurs et donc Karine Daniel qui
prend pour la première fois le rapport
pour la création la transmission des
savoirs l'emporté par Sylvie Robert que
je salue
merci Madame la Ministre tout d'abord je
souhaite évoquer les sujets qui touchent
l'enseignement supérieur de nombreuses
écoles d'art territorial sont
aujourd'hui dans une situation
financière critique et un certain nombre
d'entre elles sont menacées de fermeture
donc on constate évidemment vous l'avez
évoquer des ouvertures par ailleurs mais
ce sujet peut peut nous inquiéter même
si il y a eu une contribution à la
hausse pour 2024 23 qui est recondruite
pour 2023 et vous avez commandé un
rapport à à pierre Oudard qui a été
remis officiellement il y a 15 jours
donc à quoi l'État est-il prêt à
s'engager pour l'avenir de de ces écoles
et comment éviter que se creuse l'écart
entre entre différents établissements et
donc en terme d'accès des étudiants sur
le sur le territoire au au sujet de
formation
artistique le deuxè point de de mon
interrogation concerne le volet
territorial de de la politique qui nous
intéresse ce soir je considère que on a
un enjeu primordial de la présence des
services publics culturels sur les
territoires les plus sensibles dans les
quartiers prioritaire mais aussi dans
les espaces ruraux euh on sait que dans
ces dans ces périmètrre géographique
spécifique la culture constitue un
vecteur particulièrement puissant
d'émancipation et de développement donc
audelà des appels à projet du type de
ceux que vous avez lancé dans le cadre
de l'été culturel qui compte que compte
faire l'état en 2024 pour développer ses
services publics dans les zones les plus
éloignées et pour accompagner les
projets des acteurs associatifs et
culturels qui œuvre en ce sens quel type
de projet soutient par exemple le fond
pour l'innovation Territoriale récemment
créé comment sarticul-il avec les
politiques territoriales déjà menées
jusqu'ici et et j'ajoute avec les
actions des collectivités qui œuvre dans
ce dans ce domaine sur cette même
thématique je note que mes collègues de
la commission des finances ont relevé
une utilisation moins intensive du passe
culture pour les jeunes ruraux du fait
de leur plus grand éloignement des de
l'offre culturelle donc c'est
particulièrement vrai pour les 15- 17
ans pour lesquels se posent des
questions spécifiques de mobilité donc
on peut être interrogé sur sur ce sujet
Quels sont les consignes données à la
SAS passculture en ce sens et enfin je
voulais souligner l'amélioration que
constitue le volet collectif du Pass
culture mais il conviendra d'évaluer là
aussi les enjeux d'égalité d'accès pour
les différents établissements et nous
sommes aussi particulièrement vigilants
à l'articulation qui est
faite avec ce qui existait précédemment
dans le champ de l'éducation artistique
et culturelle et à ce que cette nouvelle
offre soit lisible à la fois pour les
acteurs culturels pour le corps
enseignant et aussi pour les
collectivités territoriales qui œuvre
dans ce domaine aux différents niveaux
de de formation donc voilà quelles sont
aussi les garanties qui peuvent être
données par par la SAS du du
passeculture dans ce domaine je vous
remercie de votre attention merci et le
tout dans le temps est parti Cédric Vial
nouveau rapporteur pour l'audiovisuel
public merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre tout d'abord merci
pour le choix du poëme qui raésonne avec
des discussions que nous aurons demain
en commission et et lundi soir avec vous
sur le langage dit inclusif je trouve
que c'est un signe politique fort que
vous avez donné en choisissant ce poème
devant nous aujourd'hui euh madame la
ministre j'ai j'ai trois trois questions
qui qui vont concerner le le financement
de l'audiovisuel public puisque pour le
coup nous ne sommes pas dans le en même
temps mais plutôt dans le entre deux
c'est que le le l'audiovisuel public est
financé par ces conventions d'objectif
et de moyens nous avons dû faire un
avenant enfin vous avez dû faire un
avenant l'année dernière à ces
conventions que le Sénat n'avait avait
d'ailleurs pas pas ratifié et nous
attendons les nouvelles conventions
d'objectif et de moyens pour les quatre
prochaines années mais alors que nous
allons voter lors du PLF
euh ce financement nous n'avons toujours
pas pu jeter un œil à ces conventions
d'objectifs et de moyens puisque dans le
PLF vous projetez déjà sur les trois
prochaines années dans un ce que vous
appelez un programme de transformation
et donc nous allons voter des des des
moyens sans objectifs ni convention donc
je voulais savoir si vous pouvez nous en
dire un petit peu plus sur la visibilité
que vous pouvez donner à la
représentation nationale puisque vous
prenez un certain nombre d'engagement
auprès sur 3 années auprès des
l'audiovisuel
public 105 encore mieux sans sans
forcément avoir encore le l'accord ou
l'autorisation des législateurs que nous
sommes qui votons encore dans notre pays
le les budgets euh donc premier point
deuxièmement pour ne pas décevoir Max
Brisson qui qui avait dévoilé le fait
que je poserai cette question n nous
souhaiterions savoir où vous en êtes
aussi dans la la réflexion sur la
compensation de de la redevance
audiovisuelle par qui est qui a été
provisoirement
euh compensé par une une part de TVA ça
sera le cas encore cette année on sait
que cette mesure ne pourra pas être
Périne sans passer là aussi par le
législateur que que que nous sommes donc
voulais savoir où où où en étaient vos
réflexions et et et à quelle échéance
vous envisagez de de pouvoir nous
proposer une une solution devant le le
Parlement et ensuite de deux deux autres
questions qui qui se rejoignent
finalement sur le l'approche que vous
avez eu vis-à-vis des des sociétés
audiovisuelles euh qui n'a pas forcément
été le le choix aussi proposé par le
Sénat de de de réformer le la
gouvernance mais plutôt de travailler au
cas par le cas à la fois sur le
rapprochement entre France Bleue et
France 3 est-ce que vous pouvez nous en
dire un un un petit peu plus sur où vous
en êtes vous attendeiez un certain
nombre d'économies sur ce rapprochement
est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner euh à
la fois peut-être des des estimations et
et des délais sur les économies que vous
attendez de de de ces rapprochements et
et nous dire un peu où vous en êtes dans
le où vous pensez dans le la
mutualisation de de notamment des
rédactions ou du travail qui est fait en
commun euh une question similaire sur
France Info et France 24 euh sur comment
voyez-vous le développement concomitant
de ces deux chaînes dans un
environnement où celui de l'information
est très concurrentiel et euh comment
pensez-vous qu'elles peuvent être
amenées à coopérer là aussi pour éviter
des coûts redondants je vous remercie
mon cher collègue Jérémie bi qui est
toujours rapporteur pour le cinéma merci
Monsieur le vice-président madame la
ministre à mon tour de de vous remercier
pour votre propos introductif mais
également pour un pour pour votre poème
fort à propos je j'essaiai à mon tour de
de rester dans les 3 minutes et de pas
être le premier mauvais élève de la
soirée donc j'auraai simplement trois
questions à vous poser comme vous le
savez avec mes collègues Sonia de la
provuté mais aussi boulet espéronier
nous avons rendu publique un rapport sur
le cinéma au printemps dernier et nous
avons même déposé ça a été rappelé par
Max Brisson une proposition de loi dans
la ligée de de nos travaux qui appelle à
la création d'engagement de diffusion
soit une nouvelle obligation pour les
distributeurs je voudrais vous entendre
et avoir votre avis sur quel devrait
selon vous être en être le champ et
êtes-vous prête à faire évoluer la
classification d'art et DESC euh pour
pas utiliser le terme dans un sens plus
restrictif au moins un recalibrage entre
guillemets de de cette catégorie là la
deuxième question euh à l'initiative de
notre collègue Catherine concon le Sénat
a adopté une proposition de loi sur la
distribution de films en outrem cette
proposition de loi vise à palier l'échec
des négociations entre les exploitants
et les distributeurs à ce jour elle n'a
toujours pas été inscrite à l'ordre du
jour de l'Assemblée nationale est-ce que
vous avez pour votre part quelques
éléments de calendrier une idée ou bien
savoir si des négociations ont repris
dans ce lapse de temps
euh pour savoir si on peut y attendre
évidemment une issue positive et enfin
dernière question pourriez-vous nous
faire un point sur les négociations
autour de la chronologie des médias qui
constitue le cœur de notre exception
culturelle en matière de cinéma je vous
remercie merci Pierre-Antoine Lévi qui a
la lourde tâche de remplacer Michel
logier pour la presse merci Monsieur le
vice-président
de me mettre la pression pour remplacer
l'excellent Michel logier qui n
malheureusement pas pu se joindre à nous
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
le soutien une presse garante de la
qualité du débat démocratique constitue
un axe fort de not des travaux de notre
commission les sujets d'inquiétudes sont
cependant très nombreux dans un monde où
l'opinion surpasse la raison il est donc
primordial que notre assemblée se tienne
au côté d'une presse dans le modèle
économique est aujourd'hui bien fragile
et où l'intervention de l'État dans ses
modalités comme dans son volume est un
sujet de débat madame la ministre je vis
donc vous poser trois questions en lien
avec mon collègue Michel logier première
question les aides à la presse sont
régulièrement critiqué pour leur opacité
et leur complexité par ailleurs elles
sont concentrées sur la presse papier et
ne prennent que marginalement en compte
le numérique comptez-vous lancer le
chantier de la
réforme les états généraux de
l'information ont été lancés début
octobre avec un an de retard sur
l'annonce du président de la République
qu'attendez-vous de cet exercice dit
depuis les états généraux de la presse
écrite de 2008 quel problème avez-vous
d'ors et déjà identifié enfin la 3è
question l'année 2024 est en théorie la
dernière de soutien exceptionnel de
l'État à France messagerie héritier de
prestalis soutien qui il faut le
rappeler et ponctionner sur les crédits
destinés à la modernisation de la presse
comment voyez-vous l'année
2025 ne serait-il pas t de renverser la
table pour pour parvenir à une solution
à une seule messagerie ou bien
spécialisé France messagerie sur la
seule presse quotidienne régionale je
vous
remercie merci enfire Martin levrier en
rempassement de notre nouveau rapporteur
Michel kouimou et took pour le livre et
les industries culturelles merci
monsieur le Président merci madame la
ministre pour vos propos liminires et
pour votre poème qui effectivement nous
rappelle combien chaque être humain
chaque homme chaque femme est finalement
une œuvre d'art et une uvre d'art unique
et
intouchable quelques questions suite au
rapport de not trcien collègue Julien
jeton qui malheureusement n'est plus
parmi nous l'idée d'une taxe sur le
streaming pour le financement du Centre
national de la musique s'est imposée
dans le débat public où en tes-vous des
réflexions sur ce sujet et un arbitrage
a-t-il été pris sur cette
question deuxème question les relations
entre les auteurs et les éditeur sont
marqués depuis plusieurs années par une
grande méfiance et les négociations qui
semblent ne pas aboutir pourriez-vous
nous dire où vous en êtes à ce sujet et
si des dispositions de nature
législative pourraient s'avérer
nécessaires
notre commission dans le sillage de
Sylvie Robert a été très active sur la
question des bibliothèques pourriez-vous
nous faire un point sur les résultats
concrets du plan bibliothèque les moyens
mis en œuvre et les perspectives pour
les années à
venir la crise sanitaire a eu un impact
majeur sur les industries culturelles et
créatives il est encore convalescent
pourriez-vous dresser un bilan un bilan
des mesures spécifiques pardon mis en
place pour soutenir les artistes et les
professionnels de la culture pendant
cette difficile période
les musées et les institutions
culturelles ont été confrontés à des
défis importants en matière de
conservation et de numérisation du
patrimoine culturel pouvez-vous nous
donner un aperçu des investissements
réalisés dans ces domaines et des
projets en cours pour préserver et
promouvoir notre patrimoine culturel et
enfin la France est réputée pour son
soutien à la création artistique comment
le ministère encourage-t-il la création
artistique innovante et comment
favorise-t-il l'émergence de nouveaux
talents en particulier dans dans le
contexte de la révolution de la
révolution numérique je vous remercie
merci avant de vous donner la parole
madame ministre je voudrais saluer notre
collègue Didier rombau rapporteur
spécial de la commission des finances
qui assiste à nos travaux madame la
ministre pour répondre à cette première
série de questions de nos
rapporteur merci beaucoup euh sur le
sujet effectivement patrimoine et
transition écologique sobriété
énergétique on on
rejoint la grande majorité des constats
et des propositions de de votre rapport
chè Sabine Drexel évidemment on il est
tout à fait possible de concilier ces
deux ambitions transition énergétique et
conservation du patrimoine bâti nous
avons les ressources les atouts pour le
faire les métiers euh et c'est ça
nécessite beaucoup de dialogue et de
concertation
évidemment au niveau local mais c'est
c'est extrêmement important comme on a
su le faire pour les euh euh tuile
photovoltaïque et le développement du
photovoltaïque on a pu s'entendre avec
le ministère de la transition écologique
sur une circulaire commune et un cadre
c'est quelque chose qu'on c'est le même
type de travail qu'on a engagé pour euh
la réalisation des DPE la la un un guide
à destination des diagnostiqueurs pour
qu'on révise ensemble ces ce cadre-là et
euh qu'on puisse travailler aussi sur le
référentiel de compétence le cycle de
formation des diagnostiqueurs et
auditeurs dans
d'actualiser tous les textes
réglementaires donc c'est vraiment
énormément de points que vous avez
soulevés sur lesquels nous travaillons
avec le
MTE on soutient aussi votre initiative
pour élargir l'attribution du label de
la Fondation du Patrimoine aux travaux
intérieurs ça rendrait possibles des
déductions fiscales ou des subventions
attachées à ce label pour des travaux de
rénovation thermique du bâti ancien ça
c'est tout à fait juste il y a les
sujets d'évolution de la fiscalité que
vous avez mentionné et et l'évolution de
la liste des travaux éligibles au prime
à la rénovation énergétique pour pouvoir
prendre en compte des travaux
respectueux du patrimoine ça c'est aussi
une piste intéressante que nous sommes
en train d'explorer avec Bercy en tout
cas soyez assurés de notre détermination
sur toutes ces questions y compris au
niveau européen parce qu'on en parle
avec tous nos collègues en Europe on
n'est pas les seuls concernés sur ces
sujets concernant
l'archéologie préventive
effectivement
euh on avait fait un effort particulier
l'an dernier hein parce qu'il y a à peu
près une 6ixaine de collectivités
habilitées par le ministère de la
Culture et le ministère de
l'enseignement supérieur pour réaliser
des diagnostics archéologiques
euh là en 2024 on avait un besoin urgent
de de rattrapage sur l'INRAP et de de
financer des revalorisations salariales
donc dans les choix que j'ai eu à faire
des efforts que que j'ai pu obtenir
supplémentaire sur le budget on a on a
priorisé cette cet engagement là mais
bien sûr on reste ouvert et on discute
avec les collectivités pour voir il faut
qu'on arrive à objectiver plus le besoin
pour mieux le défendre dans les
prochaines discussions budgétaires donc
si vous pouvez nous aider là-dessus ça
sera très utile
euh concernant les dispositifs malerau
de Normandie en fait on a j'attends une
une mission des deux inspections des
affaires culturelles et des
qui est en voie de se conclure je
regarde mon conseil patrimoine je n'ai
plus la
datentate fin de l'année bon faudra être
encore un tout petit peu patient je
pensais que c'était plus tôt mais ce
sera la fin de l'année donc je vous
ferai un retour assez vite là-dessus
parce qu'on attend effectivement des des
pistes de
d'ajustement concernant les écoles d'art
pour répondre à Karine Daniel je je l'ai
dit dans mon propos liminaire ça reste
vraiment un
chantier extrêmement prioritaire pour
nous mais n'oublions pas que ces écoles
d'art territoriales elles ont été créées
à l'origine par les collectivité elles
ont fonctionné longtemps en régim
municipal elles sont devenues des EPCC
finalement il y a pas si longtemps que
ça à partir de
2011-22 aujourd'hui on essaie de prendre
en phasage des priorités pour être au
côté de celles qui sont les plus en
difficulté le rapport Oudar on est
encore en train de euh
d' d'en retenir les les principales
conclusions et dans et de les discuter
avec tous les concernés directeurs
président de ces écoles en tout cas on
continuera à être très attentif au cas
par cas il y a pas vraiment de mesure
général parce que chaque école a son
histoire particulière et et ses
spécificités sa relation avec les
collectivités aussi certaines sont en
grande difficulté d'autres pas euh les
adossements à des universités parfois
sont des bonnes pistes parfois pas donc
il faut qu'on regarde à chaque cha fois
les différentes solutions nous déjà
l'effort supplémentaire qu'on avait fait
en en 2023 a été mis en base et c'était
pas juste une subvention exceptionnelle
qui disparaissait en 2024 on a des aides
à l'investissement aussi parce que ça si
ça peut permettre certains travaux qui
aussi réduiront les coûts de
fonctionnement on doit pouvoir les
faire donc on reste
mobilisé je vous ferit passer à la fin à
la fin de cette année on aura fait la
première année du fond d'innovation
territoriale
je précise donc le bilan n'est pas
encore prêt mais il le sera en début
d'année prochaine que chaque projet
financé les si le projet est évidemment
aussi porté avec au moins une
collectivité locale c'est sont des
projets qui sont choisis avec les élus
locaux ce ne sont pas nos DRAC tout seul
qui décident avec donc priorité aux
zones rurales isolées priorité aux
quartiers politiques de la ville avec
des projets le plus innovants poss
possiblees pour toucher des publics
qu'on narrive pas à toucher d'habitude
je pourrais vous donner énormément
d'exemples au cours de mes différents
déplacements notamment cet été où j'ai
pu en voir une grande partie mais on
vous fera on vous consolidera un bilan
dès qu'on aura la vision
d'ensemble vous avez raison de de
pointer le le sujet du passeculture en
en zone rurale on a différentes
expérimentations aussi en cours
notamment en grand test
pour améliorer sur les transports la
connaissance des des propositions et les
parcours qu'on peut faire pour les
jeunes donc ça on essaie de renforcer on
a donné effectivement des consignes
comme vous le disiez à la société du
passeculture pour travailler davantage
en ce sens eu s'agissant de la part
collective l'enjeu de cette part
collective c'est que ça vienne amplifier
l'éducation artistique au collège et au
lycée je je suis très inquiète s'il y a
des effets d'éviction si soit des
collectivités décident de retirer des
budgets qu'elles avaient initialement
sur l'éducation artistique en collège et
lycée puisque il y a le passeculture qui
est à 25 € par élève par an qui permet
de financer des actions ou si euh ça
euh pénalise des actions existantes qui
visiblement ne se feraient plus d'après
ce que vous dites moi j'ai pas eu des
remontées précises sur ça mais je je
veux bien des exemples pour qu'on puisse
y travailler au cas par cas euh parce
qu'effectivement il y a un un logiciel
du ministère de l'éducation qui
s'appelle adage qui doit référencer les
propositions sa
se se coordonner s'articuler avec le
passculture donc il y a eu un petit
calage technique au début qui a pu
prendre un peu de temps normalement
maintenant les les bugs techniques ont
dû être résolus et normalement ça
fonctionne et il y a forcément un une
une vérification de qui sont les
artistes qui interviennent en milieu
scolaire quelles sont les compagnies
c'est c'est normal que quand même un
regard de l'éducation national sur les
projets qui sont proposés mais je si si
ça éjecte entre guillemets des
compagnies ou des projets qui étaient
habitués à intervenir dans certains
établissements ça pose question donc je
je regarderai plus
précisément pour revenir à l'audiovisuel
public sur pour répondre aux différentes
questions de de Cédric Vial les com
effectivement on a voulu se donner le
temps et c'est ce que j'avais présenté
l'été dernier avec la la fin de la
redevance et la nécessité de discuter
ensemble d'abord des objectifs avant de
parler des moyens et de se mettre
d'accord sur quelles sont ces missions
de service public importantes qu'on veut
réaffirmer pour l'audiisuel public c'est
c'est pour ça que cette ce prolongement
d'un an avec un avenant descom a été
utile pour ça on a pu pu redéfinir ses
grandes priorités euh définir au sein de
ces priorités lesquelles nécessitent
plus de coopération entre les
entreprises du public pas toutes euh
mais sur certains sujets notamment
l'information sa fiabilité
l'investissement dans la lutte contre
les fausses informations
autant le faire ensemble que séparément
parce que c'est des investissements
technologiques intelligence artificielle
algorithme et cetera euh la stratégie
digitale on a pu le voir dans différents
pays européens où en fait le le les les
les plateformes numériques sont séparé
pour l'audio et la vidéo la plupart du
temps ça n'empêche pas d'avoir de
l'interopérabilité entre les plateformes
et de de travailler sur tout de même des
coopérations mais c'est pas sur
l'ensemble c'est pas une plateforme
unique par exemple donc voilà on a pris
chaque sujet on a pu avoir plusieurs
échanges ici sur ces différents axes
aujourd'hui euh on propose une
trajectoire sur 5 ans parce que je
m'étais engagé à cette visibilité euh
évidemment et je l'ai dit dans mon
propos liminaire on sait très bien que
c'est c'est au Parlement d'adopter le
budget donc et de discuter des comes et
de valider ces comes donc toutes ces ces
discussions là auront lieu le calendrier
précis DESC je l'ai plus là tout de
suite en tête mais ça va arriver là dans
les prochains mois vous aurez un
moment j'ai perdu la feuille c'est pas
très grave la la la primeure évidemment
de ces de ces documents concernant la
modalité de financement au-delà de 2025
parce que là on a encore un peu de temps
toute l'année 24 toute l'année 25 avec
le fléchage d'une fraction de la TVA
déjà collectée j'ai eu l'occasion à
plusieurs reprise d'exprimer mon avis
personnel sur le FUS et que je suis
favorable à la pérennisation de cette
modalité de financement qui implique une
modification de la LOLF une modification
qui ça très ciblé euh il n'y a pas
encore d'arbitrage interministériel sur
le sujet et les les discussions se
poursuivent mais moi je j'ai déjà
exprimé mon avis donc je le redis vous
m'avez posé la question de la réforme de
la gouvernance c'est vrai qu'on avait eu
ces échanges suite à la proposition de
création d'une holding et après
énormément de réflexion d'échange de
consultation j'en étais venu à la
conclusion que nous pouvions arriver aux
mêmes objectifs sans la création d'une
holding en allant plus vite puisque le
temps d'une loi le temps de la création
d'une holding et le coût que ça
représente on serait déjà je ne sais pas
quelle année avec je ne sais quel budget
alors que là dès 2024 en fléchant cette
enveloppe complémentaire dédiée au
chantiers prioritaire aux
transformations aux coopérations on a 3
ans fléchés pour accélérer sur ces
réformes donc j'espère cette nouvelle
méthode portera ses fruits et permettra
d'atteindre les mêmes objectifs que ceux
qui étaient souhaités euh par euh les
les sénateurs et les députés qui
s'étaient engagés sur ces questions et
notamment le président Laurent Lafond
euh concernant France 3 France
Bleue il faut regarder les chiffres en
face les coopérations ne vont pas dans
l'immédiat générer des économies le but
premier n'est pas de générer des
économies il est de grouper les forces
de l'oduselle publique qui a un réseau
extraordinaire de de proximité pour
porter un un programme ambitieux d'un
véritable média de la vie locale pour
une information locale la plus euh forte
diversifiée possible mais aussi au-delà
de l'information des services locaux une
connaissance de la vie culturelle locale
et cetera donc cet enjeu de la proximité
il nécessite différents rapprochements
sur lesquels les présidentes de Radio
France et de France Télévision ont eu
l'occasion de s'exprimer encore
récemment et on leur fait confiance pour
avancer à rythme plus rapide désormais
sur cet enjeu puisque les les budgets
complémentaires dédiés sont réservés en
partie aussi à ce chantier-là concernant
France Info et France24 c'est un sujet
plus complexe parce que on s'adresse pas
au même au même cible au même public
donc c'est pas la même fabrication de
l'information en quelque sorte il y a
des dimensions complémentaires il y a
des dimensions très différentes euh mais
il y a déjà des coopérations hein
évidemment euh entre France 24 et France
Info les je pense que dans vos
différentes auditions les les
présidentes ont pu vous en parler et on
sera vigilant à voir les segments sur
lesquels renforcer ces coopérations mais
là on est davantage en priorité sur
consolider l'information en général
consolider France Info notamment qui a
un rôle assez leader sur le numérique et
rapprochement France 3 France Bleue en
priorité pour pour les les deux trois
prochaines
années concerne
le
cinéma merci à Jérémy by donc
effectivement on a eu le rapport de
Bruno laerre qui ouvre des perspectives
très claires c'est un rapport
extrêmement sérieux et utile pour faire
évoluer clarifier les engagements de
produc de programmation qu'est-ce qu'on
entend par la réess assouplir aussi les
les les politiques tarifaires les cartes
illimitées pour les circuits donc tout
ces dispositions nécessitent une
transposition législative
donc cette proposition de loi est très
bienvenue nous la
soutiendrons pour mettre en pratique
toutes ces toutes ces
évolutions la chronologie des médias ça
reste un débat par ailleurs complexe au
sein de la filière il y avait déjà eu
des premières avancées les discussions
se poursuivent il y a eu aussi de
nouvelles avancées sur ce qu'on appelle
l'étancher des fenêtres euh et les les
discussions
continues concernant la presse là
énormément de sujets très importants
euh les états généraux de l'information
viennent de démarrer avec un comité de
pilotage indépendant que vous pourrez
bien sûr rencontrer autant que vous le
souhaitz et qui ont mis en place des
groupes de travail et il y a des sujets
très vastes qui seront traités euh moi
ce que j'en attends d'une part c'est
déjà une mobilisation au-delà des
experts sur ces sujets mobiliser les
citoyens mobiliser les jeunes mobiliser
dans les lycées avec le passeculture de
de créer du débat sur qu'est-ce que
c'est ce droit à être informé euh et le
droit d'informer dans notre démocratie
qu'est-ce qu'une information quelle est
la fiabilité d'une information en fait
de contrairement aux états généraux de
la presse là on est vraiment sur les
états généraux de l'information donc on
est au-delà du sujet de du modèle
économique de la presse de l'avenir de
la presse c'est la l'accès à
l'information dans notre société qui
passe aussi par le numérique qui peut
passer
par des des décryptages d'information
par des relais qui ne sont pas au départ
des journalistes comme Hugo descrypt ou
d'autres donc on doit prendre en compte
toutes ces modalités là et pour lutter
contre la désinformation on a tout un
chantier également d'éducation au médias
à renforcer donc j'attends aussi des
propos ition là-dessus des propositions
qui pourront mener peut-être à des
évolutions législatives sur les sujets
de concentration des propositions sur
l'évolution des aides à la presse des
propositions aussi sur comment lutter
contre les ingérences étrangères qu'on
voit qui se multiplie dans ce chaos
informationnel global donc énormément de
chantiers très importants qui
s'ouvrent et effectivement sur les aide
à la presse je m'étais engagé à ouvrir
ce chantier c'est quand même un château
de carte très complexe avec une histoire
qui qui justifie chaque étage n'oublions
pas le le point de départ qui est de
préserver de garantir le pluralisme de
la presse de sa distribution mais on ne
peut pas effectivement être aussi absent
de la presse en ligne ce qui a eu un
désajustement mais ça ça manque encore
je vous rejoins là-dessus donc ça fera
partie des des chantiers à venir France
messagerie ça j'avais bien suivi ce
sujet alors rappelons aussi que l'aide
en question c'est 9 millions d'euros
c'est pas une aide à à France messagerie
en tant que tel c'est une aide aux
éditeurs de la presse quotidienne
nationale d'IPG information politique et
général pour alléger pour eux le coût
des barêes tarifé par la messagerie des
quotidiens elle fait partie de l'aide à
la distribution globale qui est de 27
millions d'euros versés à ses quotidiens
sans cette aide les éditeurs feraient
face à des barèes qui pourrai pas
acquiter sauf à augmenter très fortement
le le prix de leur titre et ces 9
millions originalement ils étaient
ponctionnés sur notre fond stratégique
pour le développement de la presse le
FSDP et il y a eu tous les protocoles de
sauvetage au moment de la liquidation de
prestalis la création de France
messagerie et ils ont été reconduits en
budgétisation en fait par les lois de
finances depuis euh ça s'est pas traduit
pour autant par un manque de financement
de la modernisation hein dont pourrai se
plaindre les éditeurs notamment grâce à
l'intervention entre 2020 et 2022 des
crédits qu'on a pu avoir dans le plan de
relance euh on a lancé là aussi une
mission d'inspection des affaires
culturelles et des Finances pour
réfléchir pas seulement à la situation
économique de France messagerie mais à
l'avenir global de la distribution de la
presse au numéos en France son
financement l'aide à la distribution la
péréquation la gouvernance la
structuration enfin c'est c'est un
chantier assez énorme donc on attend là
aussi leurs recommandation c'est encore
un peu tôt pour moi pour me prononcer
mais je sais que vous connaissez bien le
sujet qu'on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler on attend les conclusions de de
ce rapport
d'inspection
euh concernant la musique je me tourne
vers Martin levrier alors le Centre
national de la musique
sujet pardon je vous avais perdu de
c'est au milieu c'est un sujet qui nous
a beaucoup occupé ces derniers mois le
président de la République comme vous
l'avez dit a a fait des annonces assez
fortes le 21 juin m'a chargé de mener
une concertation qui a pris 3 mois assez
intensees avec tous les segments de la
filière euh trois hypothèses sont
ressorties de ces échanges la première
c'est une contribution obligatoire avec
un tôaux modulés avec des seuils selon
les chiffres d'affaires réalisés en
France des plateformes de streaming
gratuites comme payantes pouvant aller
de 0,5 % de leur chiffre d'affaires en
France jusqu'à 1,75
% qui permettrait de générer à peu
près 18 20 millions pour le centre de la
national de la musique en première année
et plus les années suivantes puisque
c'est un marché en en croissance la
deuxième hypothèse c'est d'étendre une
taxe existante qui est la
TSV pour l'augmenter et et en faire
bénéficier pas seulement le Centre
national du cinéma mais aussi le Centre
national de la musique mais ça revient à
taxer la publicité or certaines
plateformes ne fonctionne pas avec un
modèle de publicité comme Amazon et
Apple donc ça concernerait pas toutes
les plateformes et à ce stade cette
propositionlà a peu convaincu nos
interlocuteurs mais elle avait été mise
sur la table au cours des consultation
et la troisième hypothèse qui est
ressortie que nous poursuivons encore au
moment où je vous parle c'est celle
d'une contribution volontaire des
plateformes que certaines ont proposé
d'elles-mêm pour
euh abonder le budget du Centre national
de la musique donc certaines plateformes
ont fait des propositions chiffrées
écrites d'autres orales qui sont train
d'être formalisé d'autres pas encore et
nous avons donné décidé de se donner un
peu plus de temps pour pousser cette
négociation euh mais il restera toujours
l'hypothèse à un moment du chemin du
projet de loi de finances de regarder
les
amendements que je sais que vous allez
proposer puisque certains d'entre vous
m'en a m'en ont parlé pour pour voir si
cette cette solution de la contribution
obligatoire s'avère infin la meilleure
mais là on est encore dans cette phase
de discussion avec les
plateformes les
bibliothèques merci à Sylvie Robert de
son engagement sur ce sujet on aurait
énormément à dire on a
déjà sur ce cette extension des horaires
des bibliothèques un premier bilan
encourageant mais avec les difficultés
que connaissent certaines collectivités
il faut conforter en fait les extensions
d'horair qui ont pu être faites c'est à
peu près 8h30 en moyenne
dans plus de 500 collectivités euh
notamment dans des petites communes mais
voilà avec les difficultés les factures
et cetera il y a des risques de recul
donc on doit être très vigilant pour
préserver ces extensions continuer à les
soutenir j'ai été par exemple à la
médiathèque de Riv
laape qui fait partie des médiathèques
d'ailleurs qui a été attaqué pendant les
émeutes cet été eux leur extension
d'horaire a été assez significative ils
sont passés de de 25 à 38 he dans mon
souvenir et c'est déterminant
pour notamment toucher des jeunes à des
horaires où sinon il seraient en train
d'airer dans la rue et c'est pas il
c'est pas juste de les occuper dans une
bibliothèque en plus cette médiathèque
là r laap qui s'appelle l'échappé et
particulièrement magnifique avec un
espace jeux vidéo avec des espaces pour
la musique avec des activités de comptes
d'animation y compris de spectacles un
espace pour les enfants qui est
absolument fabuleux les bibliothèques
d'aujourd'hui ces médiathèques là sont
véritablement des lieux de vie et nous
c'est notre rôle aussi de les encourager
et de les soutenir financièrement à
développer ces animations
euh il y avait d'autres question
que alors vous
avez sur le le soutien aux artistes la
préservation du patrimoine culturel
comment on encourage la création je
pourrais vous en parler pendant des
heures il faut que je sois synthétique
euh peut-être mettre l'accent sur
quelques points qui me tiennent à cœur
les écoles d'art les écoles de musique
enfin tout notre soutien à
l'enseignement supérieur c'est vraiment
ça en fait c'est le soutien à
l'émergence à la nouvelle génération
d'artistes d'architectes de musiciens
qui vont dessiner le monde de demain
d'où cette priorité que je mets sur
cette pépinière de talent que sont nos
écoles mentionner aussi le programme
monde nouveau qui a été un programme de
commande assez inédit avec une méthode
complètement nouvelle on est parti du
désir des artistes de leur proposition i
de lieux de projet et on a mis à leur
service nos moyens de des équipes de
production nos opérateurs comme le
Centre des monuments nationaux ou des
partenaires comme le Conservatoire du
littoral on a soutenu 260 projets sur
toute la France avec pour beaucoup des
artistes qui n'étaient pas connus dans
tous les champs artistiques pas
uniquement dans les arts plastiques
comme souvent la commande publique était
limitée aux arts plastiques donc il y
avait aussi des compositeurs des
danseurs des écrivains des vidéases et
cetera des projets aussi avec des design
des collectifs monde nouveau va
continuer et c'est prévu dans le budget
2024 donc avec cette ambition pour la
création mais ce chantier mieux produire
mieux diffusé je j'y viens juste 2
minutes parce que c'est il y a pas que
la création il y a aussi la diffusion
vers le public donc comment une fois
qu'on a soutenu tous ces artistes ces
projets touchent un maximum de public et
dans le domaine du spectacle vivant ne
soit pas limité à deux ou trois
représentations comme c'est parfois le
cas ou de ser ou avec des tournées 2
jours dans un coin de la France on
retraverse la France pour 2 jours
ailleurs ce qui sur un plan écologique
comme économique n'a pas beaucoup de
sens donc on a on a lancé ce chantier
dans le budget 2024 il y a un budget de
9 millions d'euros qui peut paraître peu
mais c'est un budget de levier c'est
vraiment pour déclencher des
coopérations des coproductions des
tournées plus raisonnées si je puis dire
et et favoriser une diffusion plus
vertueuse qui va être être plus durable
aussi dans le temps c'est plus de durée
de spectacle et pour toucher plus le le
public voilà mais je pourrais vous
répondre sur d'autres points plus précis
si si vous le souhaitez j'espère n'avoir
rien oublié chers sénateurs et
sénatrices vous n'avez rien oublier j'ai
inscrits donc nous allons commencer et
je vous invite non pas vous madame la
ministre mais chacun a poser sa question
le plus rapidement possible Yan Chel
oui merci monsieur monieur le le
président madame la ministre j'aurais en
fait deux deux points plus précis sur
lequel je voudrais vous interpeller tout
d'abord sur le passe culture ça faisait
l'effet d'un amendement qu'on avait
déposé nous notre groupe d'ailleurs
l'année dernière c'est son extension
l'extension du passe culture aux jeunes
Français qui sont établis aussi hors de
France ça a été acté en conseil des
ministres en février dernier par contre
on a on n pas vraiment de de date de
mise en œuvre et de la manière dont ça
va se produire c'est-à-dire est-ce que
ça va vraiment s'étendre à tous les
jeunes Français qui sont établis hors de
France et bien évidemment je m'adresse
aussi à l'attaché l'ancienne attaché
culturel qui était à New York vous
connaissez aussi l'importance de notre
réseau les instituts français les
Alliances françaises le cinéma français
également mais également nos théâtres et
les librairies françaises aussi qui qui
vivent des situations très difficiles et
je pense ce passeculture le fait de
l'étendre et de le ch vers notre réseau
pourrait être aussi une bonne façon de
le faire rayonner de le faire vivre à
travers ce passe alors qu'en est-il
exactement puisque j'aurais besoin de de
clarification de de votre part sur ce
sujet et il y a un deuxième point c'est
au début du mois d'août le gouvernement
il a pris la a pris la décision de
suspendre la délivrance des visas pour
la France au ressortissant nigériens
maliens et burkinabé ça a des profondes
réperc discussion sur nos relations avec
ces trois pays je peux vous dire que
chaque jour les conseillères et
conseillers élus des Français de ces
trois pays nous faut remonter des cas
d'artistes qui ne sont plus en mesure
d'exercer justement leur métier ce sont
des échanges culturels qui sont
suspendus dans nos territoires parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de c'est nos
territoires aussi qui sont concernés par
ça et c'est aussi le président quelque
part du groupe d'études sur la
Francophonie qui vous a qui vous
interpelle sur ce sujet-là puisque nous
allons nous-même accueillir le Sommet de
la Francophonie en octobre de l'année
prochaine on peut pas dire que ce ce
genre de disposition de ce mesure
favorise le rayonnement de notre pays et
de la Francophonie puisque si ce que
vous souhaitez c'est d'abattre les
pchistes vous les renforcez en faisant
ça vous ne faites que renforcer les
pchistes puisque vous privez des
personnes qui avaient l'habitude
justement de venir dans notre pays qui
participent au rayonnement culturel de
notre p pays et vous leur dites vous
n'êtes plus les bienvenus alors alors
que ce sont des amis de notre pays et ça
c'est terriblement contreproductif je
peux vous je peux vous donner de
nombreux témoignages et n'allez pas me
dire c'est pas un problème les cas sont
réglés parce que c'est ce qui m'a été
dit ça n'est pas vrai ça n'est pas réglé
il y a énormément de cas qui continuent
à avoir lieu donc qu'est-ce que vous
comptez faire la meilleure mesure qui
sera à faire c'est d'arrêter de de de
suspendre de retirer cette décision que
que vous avez
prise merci monsieur le Président
question sur
l'audioisuel Madame la la
ministre s'agissant malheureusement de
la multiplication des crises et des et
des conflits dans dans le monde le rôle
de notre du visel extérieur est très
important et notamment celui de de
l'information et de la présence de nos
journalistes que prévoyez-vous de plus
précis dans le cadre de de cette loi de
finances pour France 24 France
médiamonde ça me semble tout à fait un
sujet d'actualité qu'est devenu la toos
madame la ministre qui a été supprimé
vous savez cette taxe sur les opérateurs
de télécommunication qui était censé
supprimer compenser pardonnez-moi la la
la la publicité supprimé après 20h elle
est tombée dans l'escarcelle de de Bery
mais c'était une taxe affectée en tout
cas votée comme telle par le législateur
s'agissant du du secteur du spectacle
vivant m la ministre comme vous le savez
il a beaucoup souffert la crise
économique la crise énergétique vous
avez développé d'ailleurs des aides
exceptionnelles qui ont été apprécié
l'année dernière et vous proposer ce ce
programme mieux produire pour mieux
diffuser malgré tout je vois qu'il est
assorti de de de quelques précision qui
est tendre à revenir un volume financier
dédié à la production similaire à celui
de 2019 à volume d'emploi équivalent euh
cet objectif nous semble inatteignable
cont tenu euh des charges salariales qui
ont été en augmentation constante depuis
2019 soit 4 ans le taux de l'inflation
la crise énergétique que j'ai évoqué
comment d'ailleurs au au cœur de de ce
secteur du spectacle vivant sera traité
particulièr la musique dont les
établissements sont déficit pas
seulement du fait du dégagement du
désengagement de certaines
collectivités territorial et je voulais
d'ailleurs sur le secteur de la musique
vous remercier Madame laamie de ne pas
considérer que la proposition de
Monsieur temp qui était de taxer ces
structures qui sont financées à 80 %
d'ailleurs par les collectivités
territoriales euh ne soit pas donc
effectif c'est important de le prendre
en considération et j'ai enfin une
remarque sur les écool d'art vous avez
affiché une ambition de rattrapage avec
le rapport
Oudart un plan progressif malgré tout
notre collègue rapporteur a raison de
souligner à nouveau des inégalités entre
école comme d'ailleurs entre les écoles
d'architecture nous avons été plusieurs
la provoté é témoin à intervenir sur
l'école d'architecture de Normandie qui
a voilà nombre d'étudiants équivalents à
d'autres et moins bien doté ne serait-il
pas non plus un peu opportun de
réfléchir à terme car les collectivités
territoriales voient leurs ressources
fiscales non seulement baisser mais
surtout ne plus avoir de levier avec la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation de
réfléchir à une dotation globale de de
fonctionnement peut-être particulière
pour les collectivités qui portent des
établissements qui sont sans nul autre
pareil sur un territoire large et qui
ont besoin voilà qui ont besoin de
financer aussi ces établissements je
vous remercie madame la merci je
m'associe à la question de catherrine de
sa sur les écoles d'art syv Robert oui
merci monsieur le Président bien
beaucoup de questions ont étai déjà posé
et notamment par nos rapporteurs moi je
vais en rajouter une couche sur le CNM
dans dans 3 semaines on va aborder la
partie recette de la loi de finances
j'ai entendu que il y avait encore des
négociations qu' avait trois hypothèses
en réalité il n'y en a que deux
contribution obligatoire contribution
volontaire moi je voudrais rappeler à
mes collègues que la contribution
volontaire rapporterait 5 million
d'euros tandis que le produit de la taxe
streaming abondait le budget du CNM à
hauteur de 20 million d'euros il y a un
an nous vous avons posé la question
madame la ministre il manquait 20
millions d'euros vous nous avez dit il
faut obje la situation on va faire ça en
crédit de gestion l'année prochaine il
faudra une ressource je pense que là il
y a une décision politique extrêmement
importante à prendre et je dis d'autant
plus
que cette maison commune va devoir faire
face à un manque à gagner du coup de 15
millions d'euros si vous décidez de la
contribution volontaire et c'est une
année particulire que cette année de
2024 puisque vous le savez il y a les
Jos et que un certain nombre de recettes
du CNM vont mécaniquement diminuer
notamment parce que il y a pendant 6
mois il va y avoir l'arrêt de grands
concerts Stade de France accord Arena ou
Paris La Défense et il y a aujourd'hui 8
millions de pertes estimées donc je
crois que vraiment au-delà de la
question financière pour moi c'est une
question de justice fiscale et notamment
de plus juste contribution des grandes
plateformes numériques je voulais en
rajouter une couche parce que je crois
que notre collègue Julien Bargeton nous
avait exposé son rapport et que la
situation était claire alors bien sûr
maintenant c'est une bataille c'est un
arbitrage et face à la puissance des
plateformes j'espère j'espère que le
gouvernement et bien choisira la
contribution obligatoire les états
généraux de l'information ont démarré
moi je trouve que c'est une très bonne
nouvelle queon ait un débat social
sociétal sur la question par contre j'ai
une question euh es ont ils ont été
percutés par une double actualité la
première c'était ce qui s'est passé pour
la journaliste d'investigation Arian
lavriilleux et la deuxième c'est que la
position de la France dans le cadre du
règlement européen sur la liberté des
médias le gouvernement a poussé pour
introduire une exception l'interdiction
d'utiliser des logiciels espions à
l'encontre et des journalistes au nom de
là je cite sauvegarde de la sécurité
nationale on sait que c'est d'ailleurs
une notion très floue hein très
extensive potentiellement très extensive
d'ailleurs comme pourrait être
l'impératif prépondérant d'intérêt
public he dans droit national et
Catherine le sait très bien
donc il y a un besoin de cohérence et je
pense qu'il n'est pas possible de tenir
un discours à l'échelle nationale
protecteur des médias des journalistes
dans le cadre de ces états généraux de
l'information et devrait en sens inverse
au niveau européen donc madame la
ministre le gouvernement ententil
revenir sur sa position d'ici l'adoption
finale du texte pour protéger tout
simplement le secret des sources je vous
remercie merci Monique
dearc merci madame la ministre jeis je
vais revenir sur l'audiovisuel public
suite à cette suppression de la
contribution pour l'audiovisuel public
Vous avez présenté Sté un budget avec
une fraction TVA destinée à garantir le
financement de l'audisuel publi certes
en augmentation mais je vous rappelle
qu'il y a une décision du Conseil
constitutionnel suite à la loi
rectificative et également à l'Assemblée
nationale de députés de votre majorité
qui ont mis en avant également le risque
de non conformité au traité
franco-européen franco-allemand qui a
permis la création d'Arté est-ce que ce
budget respecte votre engagement
vis-à-vis de l'Allemagne et plus
globalement quel est le cap pour le
financement de l'audiovisuel public
après 2024 madame la ministre mes chers
collègues je tiens à votre disposition
une proposition de loi organique que
vous pourrez consulter et on pourrait en
débattre concernant garantir
l'indépendance deel public
donc je la tiens à votre disposition et
je propose la Commission et madame la
ministre que l'on puisse en discuter je
reviens sur un autre sujet et je
reprends un petit peu ce qu'a
avancé Syvie Robert concernant les
olimèes culturells que vous avez annoncé
euh donc ces OL ces 4 millions sont
prévus au budget du ministère de la
Culture pour les Olympiades culturelles
en
2024 avec l'objectif de poursuivre le
dialogue entre sport et culture engagé
déjà depuis 2022 mais depuis janvier
2023 vous nous nous vous alertons sur
impact de l'organisation des JO sur
l'ensemble du tissu culturel français
notamment musical du spectacle vivant
qui dépend fortement de la vie
festivalière il y a des projets
culturels qui existent déjà portés par
des acteurs permanents mais qui semblent
menacés en 2024 par la mobilisation des
forces de l'ordre mais aussi des moyens
humains et matériels de de
l'événementtiel pour l'organisation des
goéos quels moyens avez-vous budgétisé
pour compenser les pertes puisqueen
définitive ces 4 millions sont prévu sur
un autre objectif c'est-à-dire les
Olympiades culturelles qui ne sont pas
les mêmes événements qui se qui
reviennent chaque anné merci merci agè
even je vous remercie monsieur le
Président je voudrais revenir également
sur le financement du Centre national de
la musique puisque des amendements ont
été déposés donc pour l'instauration de
cette taxe streaming dont nous avons été
nombreux à parler euh cette taxe
poserait plusieurs questions
elle alourdirait notamment la fiscalité
de services qui sont d'ors et déjà taxés
sur un taux de TVA de 20 % il est
important de le
rappeler ça pénaliserait également les
leaders de l'abonnement qui sont des
acteurs européens dont les marges sont
inexistante et ça passerait sous silence
la question centrale de la répercussion
de la taxe notamment sur les acteurs les
plus fragiles va-t-elle se répercuter
sur les ayants droits et sur le
consommateur ça c'était la question
qui concernait donc ces amendements mais
ce qui me rassure c'est que vous avez
confirmé en effet exploré la piste d'une
contribution volontaire des plateformes
et des ayants et des des ayants droit
cela présenterait le double avantage
d'être opérationnel dès 2024 et de
maîtriser la répercussion des efforts
consentis à chaque maillon de la chaîne
de valeur et donc ma question plus
précise est de savoir dans quel
calendrier envisagez-vous d'aboutir à un
accord sur cette contribution volontaire
je vous
remercie merci son la pourvotter
oui merci Madame la
vinistre concernant le schéma de
financement complet et péren du CNM je
je me joins à mes collègues en dans
leurs propositions antérieures et je
suis plutôt favorable à une taxe
d'ailleurs qui avait été porté par des
amendements à l'Assemblée nationale qui
on nont pas été retenu dans le 493 donc
le combat continue et menons-le ensemble
mais clairement euh le CNM qui a fait
preuve de son utilité euh confirmé par
un rapport de notre collègue Julien
Bargeton euh est aussi vécu comme étant
un outil absolument essentiel pour pour
la filière et donc cette question de
financement et de cette taxe reste
pleinement vivante et d'actualité moi je
vais inter intervenir sur les salles euh
de musiques actuelles euh qui subissent
une crise sans précédent euh lié à la à
l'inflation et euh à l'augmentation de
de de coût aussi de de des artistes qui
qui interviennent et des coups de de
production euh elles sont dans un grand
nombre en situation déficitaire
hein certains syndicats argent d'environ
20 à 30 % hein de leurs adhérents qui
sont en situation déficitaire un effort
a été fait à leur destination mais on
sait que ces salles doivent arbitrer
entre des grosses productions et puis
leur rôle essentiel en matière de
soutien à la création euh et et et à
l'émergence euh et donc avoir votre
votre avis madame la ministre au travers
de ce budget sur le le renforcement de
de de l'aide à destination des smacs ne
serait-ce que parce que il est
nécessaire dans ces moments complètement
difficiles d'accompagner ce qui mérite
de l'être est-ce qu'il a les moyens le
moins de moyens de résister c'est-à-dire
les artistes émergents les productions
les plus fragiles euh et et pouvoir euh
euh conforter les smacs dans cette
mission là concernant le passe culture
l'éducation artistique et culturelle
nous avons interrogé une ministre de
l'éducation nationale sur ce sujet qui
donc se réjouit avec vous de mener cette
question de de du du passeculture
euh rappelez quand même que c'est un
outil qui voit encore son montant
augmenter cette année il n'empêche que
la feuille de route parce que finalement
un outil est au service d'une politique
culturelle n'est pas encore tout à fait
limpide des lisible et notamment en
matière d'éducation artistique et
culturelle et on sait que
l'éditorialisation est certes un outil
intéressant mais la médiation l' est
encore plus et et en l'espèce
euh on n'arrive pas à à à comprendre
complètement comment le le le
passeculture est utilisé par les jeunes
hors milieu h milieu scolaire et
notamment on a la confirmation sur le
fait que ça ne produit pas de la
diversité culturelle de la diversité
dans l'offre culturel et que pourtant
cet outil là aurait pu l'accompagner je
vais terminer sur le patrimoine et les
Dracs où en est-on de du renforcement
des udap qui sont ces unités absolument
essentielles sur les territoire en
matière d'accompagnement et des petite
communes c'est tout à fait
complémentaire de l'aide au à
l'accompagnement du petit patrimoine et
avez-vous évoluer sur la question de
l'assistance à maîtrise d'ouvrage euh
auprès des des des architectes a des
bâtiments de France qui est un besoin
nécessaire et à nouveau redemandé
par dans les collectivités et par les
maires sur le terrain merci Marie-Pierre
Monier dans les temps s'il vous plaît ma
cher collègue merci président madame la
ministre je rebondis tout de suite sur
ce que vient de dire Sonia parce que
vous avez augmenté les les crédits
consacrés au aux études des travaux en
site patrimonial remarquable ce qui est
une bonne chose
euh ça montre un soutien à ce dispositif
qui a été créé par la loi LC en 2016 et
qui bénéficierait auprès de 900 communes
par contre je la rejoins tout à fait
parce que là elles ont besoin d'aide ell
les communes d'être accompagnées par les
personnels des udap qui sont en nombre
insuffisant et pourtant l'importance des
SPR est reconnue dans les politiques de
revitalisation des centres historiques
et réhabilitation des logements y
compris dans les programmes action cœur
de ville et petites villes demain
que le gouvernement a mis en place donc
il faudrait vraiment renforcer leurs
effectifs ils ont évalué leurs besoins à
100 et entre 100 et 150 agents
supplémentaires je rebondirai aussi sur
ce qu'a dit Sabine
Drexler les le DPE ne tient toujours pas
n'est toujours pas adapté au bâtier
ancien il n'en tient pas compte malgré
ce que vous avez dit nous avons
auditionner les associations de
sauvegarde du patrimoine alors l'espèce
fenêtre 18e est éteinte l'espèce porte
18e ancienne est en cours d'extinion et
tout ce qui concerne les
boiseries à l'intérieur bien sûr les
lambriis sont également menacé donc il
faut quand même revoir votre copie
là-dessus parce qu'on a eu beaucoup
d'alertes action une monument historique
et patrimoine monumental il y a une
hausse du fond incitatif pour le
patrimoine et vous en avez parlé euh par
contre je pensais que ce fond était
destiné aux communes de moins vous avez
dit beaucoup de communes de moins de
2000 habitants qui sont propriétaires de
monuments historiques ayant de faibles
ressources mais il apparaît que ce fond
peut être aussi attribué à des
propriétaire privés de monuments
historiques situés dans ces communes
cela représenterait 18 % du FIP je ne
remets pas du tout en cause les besoins
de soutien des propriétés privées des
monuments historiques mais je
m'interroge sur les modalités et
critères pour bénéficier de ce fond car
la taille et les ressources de la
commune d'implatation ne semble pas être
un critère pertinent des moyens
financiers dont dispose un propriétaire
privé est-ce que vous pouvez me préciser
ce point est-ce que vous avez fait dans
vos dans vos services ont fait un petit
peu un état des lieux complets sur le
FIB depuis sa
création et puis il y avait il y a eu
bien sûr le plan en faveur des petites
églises en péril mais il ne même s'il ne
relève pas directement du budget de la
culture pour
2024 il devra quand même être financé
pour compenser les crédits d'impôt prévu
à hauteur de 75 % pour les donateurs
pouvez-vous nous préciser comment ce
financement a été envisager si cela
risque d'impacter certaines lignes
budgétaires du patrimoine je vous
remercie merci Anne Ventalon à que la
question a déjà été posée oui merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
je souhaitais effectivement revenir sur
les annonces du président de la
République en faveur du patrimoine
religieux et je salue le lancement de la
collecte nationale avec la Fondation du
Patrimoine et la défiscalisation qui en
découle je souhaitez vous interroger
plus précisément sur les mesures
interministérielles novatrices annoncées
et plus précisément comment va se
traduire la valorisation des initiatives
d'usage compatible de ces lieux de culte
je vous remercie merci
adeliane merci madame la ministre je
vais je voulais porter mon propos sur
l'action patrimoine des musées de France
d'avir un satisfcite effectivement c'est
un budget en hausse mais vous l'avez
évoqué vous-même c'est un budget de
transformation que vous nous présentez
aujourd'hui et le mettre en perspective
sur le temps long effectivement sur le
patrimoine musée de France on constate
qui a une hausse importante des euh des
des budgets liés au musée mais très
largement lié effectivement à la
rénovation du centre Pompidou dans la
perspective des j enfin post joio pardon
après pour une rénovation déterminante
et essentielle néanmoins pour les musées
comme l'ensemble du monde de la culture
la crise sanitaire la crise économique
la baisse de la fréquentation dans la
période covid-19 a eu un impact très
fort sur sur les musées sur leur modèle
économique et évidemment le ministère a
été au rendez-vous avec le plan de
relance sur un un certain nombre de
projets mais aujourd'hui sur les
surcouts liés à l'inflation à l'énergie
à la baisse de la fréquentation pour
l'ensemble des musées qui ne sont pas
encore revenus à des fréquentation 2019
même si on voit des hausses importantes
les chiffres de 2022 sont assez
encourageants de ce point de vue-là mais
néanmoins remettent car quand on connaît
l'importance de la billetterie pour les
musées dans leur modèle économique
aujourd'hui cette question est
déterminante et comment puisqu'on était
sur cette perspective prospective sur 50
an du budget de transformation que vous
évoquez comment sur les budgets de
fonctionnement lorsquon lorsque lorsque
l'on retire cette part du musée Pompidou
en terme de budget comment sur les
budgets de fonctionnement le le
ministère se projette et accompagnera
les musées de de ce point de vue-là
l'autre point c'est la question des
établissements en région qui a été
évoqué effectivement on constate qu'il y
a une stabilisation des dépenses
d'intervention avec une peut-être même
hors inflation une légère baisse les CP
qui sont justement des projections sur
l'avenir de 2021 à 2027 il y a une
importance fondamentale à accompagner
demain les musées en région je le disais
par par ce que ça a été évoqué sur la
suppression de la TVA la baisse des
financements et des capacités
budgétaires des villes des
intercommunalités des départements et
des régions le rapport de la Cour des
comptes qui a été diffusé aujourd'hui le
montre bien comment est-ce que le
ministère peut proposer un soutien un
accompagnement à ces villes à ces
territoires qui ce prennent vraiment des
des des d'envie de développer leur musé
sur leur territoire et qui sont qui sont
aujourd'hui confrontés avec des grosses
difficultés financières mes deux
derniers points madame la ministre vous
l'avez avz c'est Monsieur le c'est le
président Brisson qui l'a évoqué le
budget d'acquisition et d'enrichissement
des collections qui ne dépassera pas les
100 millions d'euros cette année encore
quand on connaît aujourd'hui le marché
de l'art les différents dispositifs
existants trésors nationaux mais
aujourd'hui quand on regarde les œuvres
anciennes et le prix et les coûts et
l'inflation c'est même plus l'inflation
c'est des montants faramineux comment le
ministère se positionne et enfin dernier
point sur Viller cotteray je voulais
savoir un petit peu du côté du ministère
on parle d'un budget de 200 millions
d'euros quel sera de demain très
prochainement je crois que l'ouverture
est dans quelques jours quel sera demain
le budget en fonctionnement proposé et
attendu s'il peut être présenté
aujourd'hui mais également la
programmation qui permettra pour cet
équipement estimé à plus de 100 millions
d'euros de faire vivre dignement et
fortement cet équipement je vous remerci
madame la ministre merci Jacques
rerin merci président beaucoup de choses
ont été dites madame la ministre mes
chers collègues au-delà du fait de se
réjouir de cette augmentation de 6 % du
budget alloué à la culture qui en
réalité fait qu'il retrouve une ambition
à la hauteur de la place qu'occupe la
culture de la société moi je voudrais
vous interpeller sur le fait que 15000
communes dont 55 % sont composés de
moins de 2000 habitants qui disposent
d'un monument historique alors chacun
sait ici que les sites patrimoniaux
revêent une importance économique
sociale et surtout culturelle et c'est
un signe fort d'avoir pensé à nos
petites communes avec la revalorisation
donc du fond incitatif pour le
patrimoine de 20 millions d'euros
toutefois il est important de noter que
nombreux édifices après aux
collectivités à l'instar des édifices
religieux de nombreux frais bien sûr un
coméie ça a été dit précédemment et je
voudrais vous interroger madame la
ministre vous avez parlé de budget
transformation d'inspiration quelle
peut-être votre inspiration
lorsque cela concerne les différents
acteurs que ça soit l'état les
ministères de la Culture ministère de la
transition écologique les autorités des
concentrés les él locaux comment chacun
comment organiser vous comment quelle
méthode allez-vous utiliser pour que on
puisse collaborer dans la maîtrise
d'ouvrage tant sur un plan financier que
sur un plan de rénovation du patrimoine
bâti en sachant que l'enveloppe risque
d'être insuffisante merci merci Mathilde
Olivier merci Madame la Ministre un
premier point sur le financement du CNM
nous sommes beaucoup à en parler ce soir
vous avez parlé des différentes options
de financement celle qui aurait été la
plus ambitieuse aurait été cette taxe
streaming progressive qui devait
d'ailleurs être proposée à l'Assemblée
nationale par les groupes de la majorité
présidentielle dans le PLF mais n'a donc
finalement pas été retenu dans le 493
par le gouvernement euh vous l'avez dit
vous-même l'option 2 sur les plateformes
vidéo n'est pas vraiment satisfaisante
alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer pourquoi cette option de la
taxe streaming a été finalement écartée
par le gouvernement alors que
l'importance du soutien au CNM n'est je
crois plus à démontrer aujourd'hui et
que l'option de la contribution volant
volontaire sera largement insuffisante
j'avais une deuxième question sur le
Pass Culture et l'élargissement de ce
Pass aux jeunes Français mon collègue
Yan Chantrel en a déjà parlé donc je n'y
reviens pas et je me joins à son
questionnement où en êtes-vous sur
l'élargissement de ce passe aux jeunes
Françaises et Français de l'étranger et
puis un dernier point aussi évoqué par
ma collègue sénatrice Monique de Marco
en 2024 un certain nombre de festivals
et de concerts normalement hébergés dans
les stades ou qui ont besoin de
déploiement de sécurité important prévoi
des revenus en forte baisse et des
difficultés d'organisation liées aux
contraintes des JO quel soutien pour
ceci
prévoyez-vous merci colombe
brouselles merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président merci madame la ministre je
vous ai entendu répondre tout à l'heure
sur le fait que le passculture devait
venir compléter l'éducation artistique
et culturelle mais je vais me permettre
de de revenir sur ces deux sujets
d'abord sur l'éducation artistique et
culturelle le budget est en hausse de
1,5 % soit très largement en dessà de
l'inflation et je nous n'arrivons pas à
identifier
comment on vous vous donnez les moyens
d'attendre 5 % 100 % pardon d'éducation
artistique et et culturelle à l'école en
2024 avec un budget qui de fait sera un
budget en en régression et en tout cas
pas un budget en hausse nous voyons peu
dans ce qui nous est présenté comment
atteindre cet objectif et nous sommes
absolument personé que dans les périodes
troublés et troubles que nous vivons
l'éducation artistique et culturelle est
un des leviers pour faire du commun et
donc c'est absolument nécessaire d'y
mettre les moyens je je reviens
également sur le pas culture d'abord
parce que il faut le rappeler en
permanence le passculture n'est pas une
politique publique le pasculture est au
mieux un outil de politique publique et
doit faire sens et cohérence avec les
les autres briques euh deux question
d'abord que quels sont les enseignements
que vous tirez du rapport que l'on
pourrait qualifier en restant aimable de
à charge de la Cour des comptes il y a
quelques mois sur la mise en œuvre du
passculture ça n'est pas encore clair
pour les les sénateurs et sénatrices que
nous sommes nous voyons monter une
volonté d'augmenter les activités
collectives et notamment pour l'ensemble
des 5e et des
6e là aussi du coup interrogation quand
on met en regard
l'augmentation qui sera consacré aux
pasculture il est un peu compliqué de
voir comment on va pouvoir étendre à
l'ensemble des enfants des élèves de 5e
et de 6e avec un un budget qui augmente
peu euh donc deè question et trisème
remarque et et ce propos a été partagé
sur
en par des des des sénateurs et
sénatrices de tout bord et de toutes
origines géographiques notamment
aujourd'hui mais également en audition
avec Gabriel Atal oui la mise en place
du dispositif vous citiez à dage est en
train de mettre en place une dynamique
absolument délétaire qui exclut de
l'Inter inention
des
compagnies spectacle vivant musique
théâtre et cetera qui de fait se
retrouve écarté de pouvoir intervenir
dans des établissements auprès d'élèves
auprès desquelles ell intervenaient
auparavant et avec du coup une
fragilisation du
tissu
culturel merci jeangérrard
Paumier oui monsieur le président madame
la ministre je souhaitais à mon tour
vous alerter sur la situation d'églises
qui sont ni classé ni inscrites
notamment en milieu rural qui
nécessitent des travaux urgents et ou de
sécurité et qui sont nombreuses les les
communes y compris les plus petites
communes sont très attachés à ce
patrimoine qui souvent est le seul de la
commune l'église au milieu du village et
ils ont du mal à les financer évidemment
les draces ne peuvent pas intervenir
d'autant qu'elles ont déjà beaucoup de
mal à tenir leurs leurs engagements
financiers pour les travaux déjà engagés
pour les églises classées ou inscrites
alors madame la minist je vous demande
pas d'argent dans votre budget mais
plutôt votre intervention auprès des
préfet des départements car il me semble
que l'échelon départemental est le bon
échelon je parle en tant qu'ancien
président de département pour traiter ce
genre de choses avec un préfet très
compréhensif en indrloire où il y a un
patrimoine important on avait défini
pour les travaux de urgent et ou de mise
en sécurité 200000 € en taxe financé à
30 % par la detet et à 30 % par le
département et l'effet levier de la D
était tout à fait intéressant ce sont
des il y a ça faisait une quinzaine
d'églises à peu près par an et vraiment
les petites communes étaient très
attachées parce que ces temps
d'inflation leur priorité si on ne fait
pas un levier fort pour ces travaux urg
je dis pas l'ensemble des travaux ils ne
pourront pas se faire et ce patrimoine
va se dégrader et coûter beaucoup plus
cher quand il faudra le rénover merci
Madame la Ministre merci et enfin emerc
Duroc merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre alors que notre pays
s'apprête à accueillir les Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques l'été
prochain je souhaite vous poser une
question en lien avec l'héritage de cet
événement depuis 2006 il existe un
réseau des musées Olympiques qui fédère
32 musées dans le monde souvent
implantés dans les villes qui ont
accueilli des gios la France n'en fait
pas partie la France compte des musées
dédiés au sport par exemple le musée
national du sport à Nice le musée du
sport à Cruas des musées des fédérations
comme le basket l'automobile et cetera
ou des espaces mémoriaux olympiques dans
les villes hautes no Alberville mais n'a
pas de véritable musée du sport et de
l'olympisme sur un lieu unique Paris qui
aura accueilli trois fois les Jeux
olympiques d'été 1900 1924 2024 donc est
vu nêtre une grande partie du système
sportif international le CIO la
Fédération internationale des courses
pionnières et cetera n'a aucun lieu de
valorisation de cet héritage unique en
2021 Stéphane Fievet alors président de
la commission histoire du comité
d'organisation des Jos Paris 2024 avait
initié un projet de Musée olympique dans
la gare de Saint pleel l'État n'a pas
soutenu l'initiative les collectivités
n'ont pas voulu allouer de subvention et
le projet n'a pas survécu la à la
démission de du sus nommé madame la
ministre héritage des Joos Paris 2024 et
vitrine de notre candidature pour les
giio d'hiver 2030 la France doit combler
son retard et créer un musée olympique
qui serait toute à la fois un outil de
culture un lieu de mémoire et une
attraction touristique cet espace muséal
honorerait la France berceau de la
rénovation de l'olympisme et
repositionnerait notre pays dans le
réseau de la culture olympique je vous
remercie merci mon cher collè vous
pourrez reposer votre question demain à
Madame ministre des sport Mad oui enfin
je pourrais la reposer aussi mais ou la
reposer voilà madame madame le ministre
vous avez la parole oui alors je
commence justement par la fin et
justement dans cette année olympique
l'olympiade culturelle sur laquelle
effectivement nous nous engageons 4
millions d'euros en 2024 on avait déjà 3
million d'euros en
2023 nous permet de créer des projets
culture et sport partout et je pense
qu'il y aura un héritage très fort de
cette mobilisation inédite les forces
vives de la culture et les sources vives
du sport vous avez en ce moment par
exemple une magnifique exposition au
musée des artsdco sur la mode et le
sport on a pu faire des spectacles dans
des musées dans des piscines dans des
gymnases au moment des journées du
patrimoine il y a eu en fait des
collaborations qui vont durer après puce
que c'est une olympiade culturelle pas
sur quelques mois mais sur plus de 2 ans
et demi donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui en
France on a un tissu culturel tellement
riche je ne suis pas persuadée qu'il
faille créer des musées supplémentaires
euh sur le le sport en plus comme il y a
déjà le musée de Nice qui est quand même
un très très beau musée en revanche
qu'il y ait plus de lien entre sport et
culture partout dans les musées
existants dans les salles de spectacles
dans les festivals c'est ça que
l'olympiade culturel a permis va
permettre de déployer encore plus
fortement dans les prochains mois et je
pense que ça peut être un un héritage
assez puissant de collabor et de lien de
long terme entre deux champs la culture
et le sport qui ont énormément à
partager en terme de valeur d'ambition
et d'engagement pour pour la
jeunesse concernant le
passculture beaucoup de d'interventions
là-dessus alors le le rapport de la Cour
des comptes n'est pas tant que ça à
charge à mesure il revient sur surtout
les les les débuts les balbuements du
passeculture dans sa phase de lancement
sous Françoise Nissen euh il constate
quand même ce rapport que que le
passeculture il souligne son caractère
novateur sa pertinence comme levier
d'accès à la culture faut faut quand
même bien relire aussi ces passages qu'
il montre bien que il y a un rôle clé
dans la levée des freins à l'accès à la
culture pour les jeunes et pas seulement
les barrières financières la
connaissance de la librairie à côté de
chez soi l'envie d'y aller tout ce que
le passeculture a déployé en en guise de
justement de médiation de parcours les
premières fois la découverte des métiers
les expériences culturelles qui sont
permises sur le passculture c'est
vraiment pour moi pas uniquement un
outil d'achat de place ou de livres ou
de spectacle c'est pas un outil de
consommation le Pass Culture c'est
vraiment un outil d'engagement de la
jeunesse pour les faire participer en
faire des protagonistes de notre vie
culturelle ils sont par exemple reporter
sur des festivals il voient les
coulisses ils rencontrent les artistes
ils ont avec le plan métier d'art on a
mis en place 700 activités métiers d'art
sur le peculture pour qu'ils découvrent
ses métiers qu'il découvre des ateliers
d'artisans qu'il fassent eux même des
euh des des expériences des
expérimentations et ça fonctionne très
très bien donc voyez le passe culture
évolue tous les jours et se nourrit
aussi des propositions des jeunes
eux-mêmes on a créé un réseau
d'ambassadeurs ils sont 400 ambassadeurs
jeunes du Pass Culture sur tout le
territoire et relais euh autour d'eux
les actions du passeculture ils
inspirent l'équipe du passe-culture pour
faire évoluer les propositions et ils
contribuent eux-mêmes à à développer ce
dispositif concernant leac euh je je et
merci je connais votre engagement cher
Colomb Brusselles sur ces sujets et et
l'enjeu de que tous les enfants et et
les jeunes aent accès à une expérience
d'éducation artistique au cours de leur
parcours scolaire c'est le but de ce
plan 100 % EAC qui qui a forcément été
ralenti pendant les années de crise
sanitaire mais nous étions à autour de
75 % près de 80 % d'objectif atteint ce
que vous voyez dans le budget quand vous
voyez les les budgets du Pass Culture
ministère de la culture ou le budget
EAC ça n'est pas que ça évidemment il y
a le budget du ministère de l'Éducation
il y a 50 millions environ ministère de
l'éducation pour le passeculture
collectif mais surtout il y a tout le
budget de nos opérateurs des structures
labellisées du ministère en fait tout ce
qui est dans le budget on va dire
création diffusion mais qui sont en fait
aussi dans leur cahier des charges dans
leur mission en
priorité tourn vers l'éducation
artistique si je prends par
exemple le dispositif desmos de la
Philharmonie parce que vous vous le
connaissez bien aussi bah ça vous ça va
être sur le budget de la Philharmonie
les emplois de la Philharmonie ça ne va
pas apparaître dans le budget EAC idem
pour d'autres
dispositifs comme comm l'opération
annuelle c'est mon patrimoine qui permet
de
de de d'emmener des jeunes notamment de
quartiers politique de la ville à la
découverte du patrimoine ça va pas
forcément apparaître sur ces crédits là
ou le mumeau qui est un musée mobile du
sentre Pompidou qui parcour le
territoire qui fait escale en priorité
dans des quartiers politiques de la
ville ou dans des petits villages là
aussi ça va être le budget du Sant
Pompidou avec une aide d'ailleurs dans
mes scènes qui est la Fondation har
explora je je vais pas vous citer
beaucoup plus d'exemples mais il y a a
cet objectif d'éducation artistique et
de sensibilisation par tous les moyens
de tous les publics à la culture il
passe aussi par le rôle des opérateurs
des structures
subventionnées concernant le Pass
Culture pour les Français de l'étranger
euh c'est effectivement un engagement
sur lequel nous travaillons
d'arrache-pied avec mes collègues au
ministère des Affaires étrangères c'est
assez complexe que le passeculture c'est
une application et donc en tant que tel
l'application à déployé dans plusieurs
dizaines de pays c'est extrême
exraimment compliqué euh évidemment
qu'on a comme vous l'intuition qu'il
vaut mieux s'appuyer sur notre réseau
culturel les instituts les
alliances les consulats aussi qui
connaissent les Français en situation
sociale plus difficile et qui savent les
accompagn donc de de mettre au point euh
des propositions qui impliquent ce
réseau impliqu les libréie francophone
je vous rejoins complètement sur leur
rôle essentiel à l'étranger que nous
soutenons d'ailleurs par ailleurs avec
le Centre national du livre et euh ce
qui est plus facile à faire dans un
premier temps c'est de débloquer la
possibilité d'utiliser le passe-culture
en France pour les Français de
l'étranger quand ils viennent en France
ça c'est moins compliqué puisqu'ils
peuvent utiliser l'application en France
euh mais donc là on est en train de de
réfléchir à plusieurs hypothèses est-ce
que c'est un bon euh à à retirer dans un
institut français ou au consulat est-ce
que c'est certaines offres diffusées sur
le site internet bref on est en train de
de de consulter tous tous les acteurs de
ce réseau pour voir quelles seraient les
meilleures solutions et à adapter selon
les contextes évidemment en tout cas on
y travaille je veux vous répondre très
clairement sur la question des visas
parce que c'est faux nous n'avons pas
suspendu les coopération nous avons été
face à une situation au mois d'août
d'incapacité de travailler avec ces pays
pour des raisons matérielles des raisons
de
euh d'attaque qui ont ciblé directement
les équipes françaises et qui ont
engendré une restriction des services
voire une fermeture de nos services de
visa si vous avez encore des cas que
vous pensez être bloqué d'artistes qui
n'ont pas eu leur visa honnêtement vous
me les envoyez personnellement je vais
je vais venir vous voir avant de partir
parce que j'ai suivi personnellement
certains cas par exemple des basketeuses
du Mali qui venaient dans le cadre d'un
projet pour l'olympiade culturelle j'ai
même la photo de leur arrivée à
l'aéroport j'ai j'ai suivi chaque étape
de la délivrance de leur visa on a dû
trouver des sol solution avec le qu
d'orsé dans un contexte de restriction
de nos services pour faire avancer ces
projets quand je parle des projets de
coopération il est évident qu'avec le
Niger où nous n'avons plus d'ambassade
où une jeunte est arrivée au pouvoir
condamnée par toute la communauté
international suite à ce coup d'État une
coopération c'est dans les deux sens
donc c'est il est hors de question de
dire qu'on ne veut plus voir d'artistees
du Niger en France jamais je ne dirai ça
ils seront toujours les bienvenus on a
toujours été une terre d'accueil et
d'échange et d'ouverture en revanche il
faut bien que les Français aillent
là-bas une coopération ça se construit à
deux et ça c'est pas possible
aujourd'hui donc faut juste être
réaliste sur les dangers que pourrai
encourir des associations des structures
culturelles des artistes à aller dans
des pays où la France est directement
menacée l'Institut français de wagadougu
a été incendié souvenons-nous de ça il a
été brûlé donc on parle de situation
géopolitique extrêmement difficile dans
trois pays avec lesquels en tout cas le
Burkina et le Mali encore plus euh que
le Niger on a toujours eu des actions de
coopération très fortes je vous donne un
dernier exemple pour vous prouver que
nous savons des livré des visas et que
nous continuons à le faire on a organisé
les 6 7 8 octobre un grand forum des
industries culturelles et créatives
africaines à la Gaité Lyrique au au
Conservatoire des Arts et Métiers et au
Centre Pompidou près de 300 artistes et
professionnels africains d'une trentaine
de pays sont venus avec des visas ont
fait euh un certain nombre de rendez
vous pour certains des spectacles des
projections de film ou des concerts donc
on a pu complètement porter l'ambition
de cette coopération renforcée avec
l'Afrique qui depuis le discours de
wouagadougu du président Emmanuel Macron
est au cœur de notre ambition pour la
culture et qu'on retrouvera aussi à
villercotret puisque cette Cité
internationale de la langue française
accueillera des artistes de tout le
monde francophone en résidence il y a
une douzaine de de studios pour des
résidences y compris donc de pays
africains Kin Kasa étant aujourd'hui la
ville où il y a plus de locuteurs
francophones c'est l'épicentre de la
Francophonie en nombre de locuteurs
c'est Kinshasa aujourd'hui et on
continuera à développer des projets et
vous avez bien fait de mentionner le
Sommet de la Francophonie en 2024 mais
vraiment je je prendrai les cadres que
vous mentionnez parce que je vous assure
que il y a aucune instruction de
suspension et aucune instruction de
refus de visa il y a juste des
difficultés logistique face à une
situation sécuritaire hors du commun et
particulièrement grave dans ces pays ce
qui nous permet de faire le lien avec la
question de Madame Auran de sali sur
l'audiovisuel extérieur son importance
absolue dans ces contextes où on le sait
aussi dans certains pays africains la
désinformation est particulièrement
organisée financée par les Milis Wagner
par la Russie par exemple qui a des des
voilà des véritables guerres
informationnelles qui se jouent sur ces
territoires donc d'où le renforcement
dans cette trajectoire de 5 ans que nous
proposons pour France médiamonde avec
une hausse d'à peu près
40 millions sur 5 ans euh pour faire
face à ces ces campagnes de
désinformation s'armer plus euh et
porter la voix de la France dans toute
leur indépendance évidemment en tant que
journaliste mais en tout cas de
continuer à innover aussi sur le
numérique euh sur la stratégie
régionalisée et de continuer aussi à
promouvoir la francophonie dans un monde
plurilinguiste vous avez posé la
question sur la TOS euh qui
effectivement est reparti dans le budget
de l'État mais en fait le le budget de
l' extérieur ne baisse pas donc comme là
on a la fraction TVA on se retrouve
finalement tout ça rejoint le budget de
l'État et puis on on réaffecte dans le
compte de concours financier pour
l'audiovisuel public donc vous inquiétez
pas il y a bien un canal qui va à
l'audiovisuel extérieur de de toute
façon mais effectivement cette Toss a
été réinjecté dans le budget général on
va dire
euh concernant le le spectacle vivant on
a
euh effectivement et ça rejoint la
question aussi sur les SMAC euh on
pourra faire de nouveau des aides pour
faire face à l'inflation pour les
structures qui seront les plus en
difficulté parce que certaines sont plus
de passeoirs thermiques que d'autres et
donc auront à faire face à des factures
dans le budget général du ministère de
la Culture la hausse que je vous ai
annoncé de plus 6 % il y a 75 millions
dédiés à l'inflation donc on arrivera à
faire face à des à ces difficultés là
mais en plus nous voulons amorcer ces
transformations plus structurel avec le
plan mieux produire et mieux diffusé euh
quand on dit qu'on veut on veut pas
baisser le nombre de production ou le
volume de d'emploi c'est que moi le but
il est pas qu'il ait à la fin moins
d'artistes soutenus c'est juste que le
rythme de création soi moins intense et
que les créations soient mieux produites
avec des co-producteurs réellement
engagés et après avec des diffusions
plus longues ça veut dire de desserrer
en fait le rythme et de de permettre euh
d'étaler sur plus de temps le même
nombre de production le même volume de
travail pour euh euh toucher plus de
public aussi et pour rationaliser sur un
plan écologique les tournées euh je vous
rejoins euh tous ceux qui sont
intervenus et toutes celles sur les
écoles d'art et d'architecture on est
bien conscient des inégalités euh issu
de l'histoire d'un millefeuille de de
cision dans l'histoire qui font
qu'aujourd'hui on doit réajuster et
s'occuper des en priorité des écoles les
plus fragiles sans pour autant
abandonner celles qui sont dynamiques et
dans une progression donc on doit
réévaluer
les les
enveloppes c'est un phasage en 3 ans
qu'on va faire en fait on sera pas en
capacité de tout régler en une année
avec le budget actuel vu le l'ampleur
des difficultés mais j'ai bien
conscience de ça euh j'ai déjà beaucoup
je me j'ai à peu près tout dit je pense
sur le Centre national de la musique
euh calendrier bah vous le connaissez
aussi bien que moi c'est le
calendrier bah des des discussions au
Sénat commission des finances séances
publi donc dans les TR qu prochaines
semaines c'est c'est là qu'on voilà 15
novembre moi pour moi c'est la première
grande deadline pour voir si cette
contribution volontaire arrive à des
niveau que l'on peut estimer
satisfaisant par rapport aux objectifs
de départ ou pas
et en tout cas le le débat reste ouvert
à ce stade
euh j'ai bien conscience que l'année 24
est particulière et vous avez raison
Sylvie Robert puisque avec certaines
salles qui sont prises pour les Jeux
Olympiques on sait automatiquement que
la taxe billetterie va baisser donc on a
un cas spécifique en plus sur l'année
2024 on l'a bien on l'a bien en tête euh
h je reviens
[Musique]
sur le patrimoine et
l'enjeu des des églises au milieu du
village j'aime beaucoup cette expression
qui est très très claire de Jean-Gérard
Pomier mais vous avez raison les préfets
ont un rôle à jouer et c'est ça il est
plus là je crois mais en tout cas j'ai
pu le voir moi-même par exemple dans la
Somme ou des crédits desetr et desciles
ont pu être mobilisé à hauteur de 4
millions d'euros pour soutenir presque
100 100 opérations de de restauration
dans des églises sur une année ce qui
est quand même colossal donc
effectivement avec Gérald armanin on a
décidé de remobiliser les préfets sur
ces crédits qui sont à leur disposition
et qui peuvent leur rappeler qu'ils sont
fléchables sur des restaurations
d'églises non protégées évidemment pour
les églises que nous allons protéger
inscrire ou classer elles vont pouvoir
bénéficier des subventions du ministère
il y aura la collecte que nous qui qui
est lancé depuis les journées du
patrimoine avec la Fondation du
Patrimoine et il y a toujours le loto du
patrimoine ne l'oublions pas qui permet
aussi de soutenir des restaurations de
d'édifices cultuels non protégés ça
c'est c'est très important
euh je crois qu'il y avait d'autres
questions patrimoniales que j'ai dû ah
merci de votre engagement et soutien
pour nos udap vous avez complètement
raison sur leur rôle essentiel alors on
a plusieurs sujet il y a il y a une
question de vacances de postees à
laquelle on doit répondre parce que il y
a eu une baisse de candidats au concours
depuis plusieurs années là on a
programmé des concours donc j'espère
qu'on va pouvoir pour voir les postes
vacances ça c'est déjà la première
urgence ensuite ayons en tête qu'on peut
toujours recourir à des architectes
contractuels pour épauler nos nos ABF
c'est arrivé par exemple pour l'udab de
Saint-Denis dans le cadre des Jeux
Olympiques on a pu recruter un
contractuel évidemment on doit aussi
renforcer l'expertise technique des udap
euh revoir aussi nous comment on peut
redéployer des emplois administratifs
vers des emplois scientifiques et
techniques euh améliorer tout ce qui
touche à la
dématérialisation des procédures pour
faciliter la transformation des métiers
alléger euh euh certaines charges de
travail c'est tous ces sujets-là sur
lesquels on travaille en parallèle mais
mais merci du pléidoyer pour les udap
euh j'ai dû oublier des ch
le fond institatif pour le patrimoine
voilà dans les questions patrimoniales
la question des propriétaires privés
donc effectivement oui il ils peuvent et
puis quand on pense propriétaire privé
il faut pas voir un châelin très
riche c'est il y a toutes sortes de
propriétaires privés mais vous le vous
le savez exemple vol viicomte qui est
une propriété privée qui a déjà pu
bénéficier du FIP c'est quoi les
critères de sélection bah ils tiennent
d'abord il faut dire qu'il y a un apport
du conseil régional parce que le fond
incitatif c'est ensemble avec les
régions minimum de 15 % ce qui est pas
toujours facile hein pour les monuments
privé mais quand les régions s'engagent
ensuite l'intérêt patrimonial l'intérêt
du chantier
euh la question de l'ouverture au public
est-ce que ce sont des propriétés
privées avec des temps d'ouverture au
public pour quel type d'activité tout ça
ça permet en fait de voir si un projet
d'attractivité territoriale de
développement c'est c'est très important
important euh vous avez posé la question
aussi des usages
compatibles très beau sujet parce que si
on veut restaurer ces églises au cœur
des villages c'est pas uniquement pour
que les pierres tiennent debout c'est
aussi pour qu'elles vivent et elles
peuvent vivre soit
euh uniquement avec leur activité
cultuelle mais elles peuvent aussi vivre
avec une activité mixte si elle est
compatible avec l'activité cultuelle et
si les diocèes sont d'accord bien
évidemment donc il y a un travail un
dialogue qui est engagé avec la
Conférence des évêques et la Fondation
du patrimoine sera très attentive à ça
dans les projets qui seront sélectionnés
dans le cadre de la collecte pour des
soutien aux restauration ça fait partie
des critères ils ont d'ailleurs lancé ce
prix sésame qui est très intéressant qui
soutient des initiatives d'usage mixte
ça peut être une bibliothèque une
épicerie solidaire ça peut être des
activités de découverte de métiers d'art
de restauration de vitro et cetera
toutes ces tous ces usages nouveaux
peuvent créer une nouvelle attractivité
pour ces lieux de culte parfois aussi un
modèle économique en tout cas revitalise
ces ces édifices et ces territoires donc
on y sera très attentif je redis aussi
que dans la collecte 10 % de l'argent de
la collecte sera fléché sur des études
d'ingénierie sur du soutien en
ingénierie aux communes parce qu'une
fois que l'argent est collecté il faut
quand même pouvoir mener les travaux et
certaines notamment les toutes petites
communes ont des difficultés à à faire
la maîtrise d'ouvrage donc un budget
sera flécher là-dessus vous m'avez parlé
est de villercôteré je vous invite tous
à à visiter ce château dès que possible
après l'ouverture le 30 octobre vous
verrez la qualité de la restauration
mené par le Centre des monuments
nationaux en 4 ans hein c'est quand même
un chantier colossal parce que j'ai vu
le lieu quand j'étais concert culture à
élisé fin 2019 dans un état absolument
délabré après des dizaines d'années
d'abandon donc c'est un magnifique
chantier mené par le Centre des
monuments nationaux grâce au crédit du
plan de relance que nous avons pu
accélérer et nous avons même pu prendre
en charge le Clos est couvert d'une
partie du château qu'initialement nous
n'avions pas l'intention de restaurer
mais de laisser à des investisseurs
privés ce qui va faciliter l'arrivée de
partenaires privés pour notamment
développer un hôtel et un restaurant
juste à côté du château et le budget de
fonctionnement à la réouverture euh vous
savez en fait le Centre des monuments
nationaux c'est une péréquation entre
les 100 monuments donc c'est ça aussi
qui va permettre de sécuriser dans les
premières années euh
les le le développement de C cette cité
internationale nous avons aussi des
aides d'autres partenaires nous avons
signé une convention avec l'organisation
de la Francophonie le Québec a soutenu
Viller cotteré à hauteur de 2 million
d'euros et je veux saluer leur
engagement donc nous aurons des messenes
qui seront aussi qui vont apporter leur
budget donc on on on on a une prise en
compte un peu particulière de
villercôteray dans le global du CMN mais
grâce aussi aux fonctions support aux
équipes ressources au CMN ils pourront
s'appuy
sur cette magnifique expertise des
agents du du
CMN dernier point sur ça j'ai déjà dit
je ne sais plus
pardon sur les enjeux de liberté de la
presse pardon je crois que j'ai pas
répondu à Sylvie Robert là-dessus et de
sécurité des
sources on on a deux deux sujets
constitutionnels il y a d'une part la
préservation de la sécurité nationale et
il y a du secret défense et de l'autre
côté évidemment c'est constitutionnel la
liberté de la presse et c'est la loi de
1881 donc on on on reste extrêmement
vigilant effectivement en tant que
ministre de la Culture je je ne peux que
que toujours saluer l'engagement des
journalistes parfois au péril de leur
vie dans certains pays pour nous
informer et nous apporter les
informations les plus fiables les plus
libres les plus indépendantes possibles
les États généraux permettront
évidemment aussi des débats sur ces
sujets je sais que ça a déjà commencé
donc à suivre dans les prochains mois
mes excuses si dans toutes mes filles je
me suis emmêlé et que j'ai oublié une de
vos questions sinon vous me le rappelez
ilico personne ne semble protester donc
je pense que tout le monde pardon oui
SR sur
Oui ils sont stables je confirme
ouais mais heureusement nous avons aussi
des mécenes généreux qui grâce au
dispositif trésor national par exemple
qui a une défiscalisation
particulièrement importante c'est un
autre une autre manière d'apporter un
apport de l'État en favorisant le mesena
euh ce qui nous permet voilà d'avoir
c'est comme ça qu'on a pu ne pas laisser
partir hors de France ce magnifique
kybot la partie de bateau qui est
maintenant visible qui a été visible au
musée d'orsé puis qui a pu être installé
au musée des beauards de Lyon qui va
continuer son itinérance euh mais voilà
c'est vrai que l'enjeu des crédits
d'acquisition est très important mais
que aujourd'hui on avait voilà des
revalorisations salariales des enjeux de
lutte contre l'inflation des travaux
pour améliorer la performance
énergétique des bâtiments et que voilà
tout est important mais il a fallu faire
des choix dans ces hausses de
budget c'est bon moniqueco mais mais
juste de revenir sur le traité
francoallemand avec la création d'Arté
et également que que faire après 2024
concernant donc le financement de visuel
public peut-être ça sera des choses où
on pourra débattre plus tard voilà la
ministre a parlé on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler et alors je vais vous donner
pour ceux qui sont encore là et si on en
a assez deux documents là qu'on a amené
dans nos petits carton vous aurez le le
le dossier de présentation de Viller
cotteré pour vous donner envie de all et
euh le dossier de presse du budget du
ministère vous aurez aussi mais bon vous
avez déjà toutes les données budgétaires
mais là ce sera présenté de manière plus
vivante que les tableaux Excel que vous
avez et à la fin des annexes avec tout
le détail année par année de la
trajectoire pour le duel public dont é
j'étais en Allemagne très récemment
puisque'à Hambourg nous avons évoqué
avec la ministre allemande le cas d'Arté
et nous avons réaffirmé nos engagements
également pour le développement de la
place plateforme européenne d'Arté qui
est un enjeu très important pour
l'avenir en plusieurs langues Arté
pouvant toucher tous les pays européens
et pas uniquement évidemment la France
et l'Allemagne mais c'est prévu dans la
trajectoire et ainsi seront récompensés
ceux qui sont restés jusqu'à la fin en
tout cas merci merci madame la ministre
de ces réponses extrêmement argumenté
nous sommes restés presque plus de 2h de
non 2h 2h rester près de 2h ensemble et
merci pour vos réponses très complètes
et merci donc aux collègues qui sont
restés jusqu'au bout de cette audition
demain on se retrouve à 9h salle a245
pour le rapport de Caine Maine de sa et
els Joseph sur et après le rapport de
citric
Vial demain 9h salle dans notre salle
habituelle de
commission
merci